this is jocko podcast number 241
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
i was the number one man on the door in
my train which meant i would be the
first man into the room
missions often included debates as to
who would get to go
first all these guys were fearless
and like to train hop to the front of
the stack the most dangerous place
to be first into a room
seals love to fight we all want to be
the first into the fight and every seal
is willing to accept the greater risk
especially for his buddy's sake
i had no apprehension about the
possibility of my own death
my concern was for my platoon mates
while i can't speak for everyone their
actions this night
proved they all felt the same way
clarky and i looked at each other he
smiled back at me
we had practiced this maneuver a
thousand times and had successfully done
it on
hundreds of missions just like this one
there was no rush of adrenaline or
anxiety
we were composed relaxed and
professional
we would simultaneously breach our
respective doors
and go to work clearing the rooms of
enemy fighters and other
potential threats
we launched on the signal a mutual wave
of our rifle barrels
i breached the door to my room it swung
open to the right
i followed the door in as it opened
looked down the right wall
and saw it was clear as i pivoted off my
right foot to move down the left wall
i had the sensation that my body was
being slammed with a dozen sledgehammers
my entire body was now in the room and
the men behind me
in my room clearing train were
attempting to follow me in
the room was small 12 feet by 12 feet
my night vision goggles illuminated the
darkness and i saw
in clear view four of our targets aiming
at me all of them armed with automatic
weapons
and all of them firing at me
that right there is an excerpt from a
book
called perfectly wounded by a
retired seal named mike day and i
knew mike when he was a young seal
he was maybe 10 classes ahead of me
going through
basic seal training he started his
career at seal team three i started
my seal career next door
i don't know 50 meters away 100 meters
away over at seal team one
we crossed paths on what was my first
deployment
we'd see each other around from time to
time
he was always very cool to me from what
from what i could tell always cool to
everyone
nice guy
no ego no attitude
and on the day that mike writes about in
that book
those insurgents that were shooting at
him
they hit their mark
and not just once not just twice
not just three or four or five or ten
times
but 27
27 times mike was shot 11 times
in his body armor and 16 times
in his body
and you have to keep in mind
and this is a strange thing
but one single round
or one single tiny piece of
fragmentation
can kill you
so to receive that many shots
and survive is
well it's some kind of miracle
and then to go beyond that because the
story doesn't end there but to receive
that many shots and actually
fight back is beyond a miracle
and that's exactly what mike did
he fought back and he won
and it is an honor to have mike here
today
to tell us about his experiences his
life
and his lessons learned he's got a bunch
of them
so mike thanks for coming on man
i appreciate you guys having me uh
yeah get getting you out here i know
we're in the middle of
middle of covid right now uh you've been
driving across country
i know you just got done with the total
archery challenge up in
up in utah i i wish i could have grabbed
you there so you'd have to come all the
way down here but now you're telling me
you're going to try and look to surf a
little bit which is awesome
well i'm trying to that looks like the
surf's going to be picking up in
virginia since i'm not there
we got a hurricane coming up that's the
way it works isn't it
you should have been there
well hey man um i want to jump into this
your book
is first of all it's it's just i mean
everyone obviously i'm not going to read
the whole book i'm going to read some of
it
just go and go and get the book right
now the
the detail that mike goes into this is a
historical document about being in the
seal teams
about being in combat and and then
what's
in addition to that the life stories
that you bring to the table
are important for people to understand
understand what
how people grow up in different
situations what it does to them
and how to get through those hard
situations because
you definitely went through some hard
situations
so i'm gonna jump into it man
jump into this book and kind of talk
about your past and how you grew up and
it starts off like this he looked huge
like a damn monster
she was screaming and fighting back
which only made it worse
i was frozen in terror he bent her
arm over his knee and like a twig
cracked it
i watched him break her arm
he yelled at me go get me a glass of
water i ran to the kitchen filled the
glass and ran back to hand it to him he
drank it
then smashed the glass on a nearby table
and held the broken shard like a knife
he went after her again with this newly
created blade
i jumped on his back to stop him i think
that's what finally snapped him out of
his
uncontrolled rage i flew off him as he
swung his arm and i landed on the ground
on my back he spun around to attack his
unknown aggressor
and realized it was me
i clearly remember seeing his expression
dissolve from rage
into one of guilt and shame
this is my earliest memory and my first
encounter
with a terrorist it was 1976 in new
jersey
and the terrorist was my father
his victim was my mother
i was five years old
that's your earliest memory
seal teams were easy he made it easy
yeah this is i believe pretty privilege
in our society now a lot of us have just
terrible parents
and one of the one of the best books
i've ever read is
the body keeps a score and he says in
that book the
largest medical issue the largest
medical problem we have in this country
is childhood trauma because it
you learn what you are in the first
seven years
you know for me luckily it wasn't to the
point where
i became more of a victim
and and worried about what things were
going to happen
my response was just a fight so when i
get scared
or angry now i fight when i get scared
a lot of people when they get scared the
fight or flight
is is to cower
you can see in a lot of a lot of
gunfights with people that aren't
trained
one of the most prominent places to get
shot somebody that doesn't know what
they're doing is in their in their
forearms and their hands it's because
they're cowering
and our
when we get triggered like people know
that you don't jump around a corner
to scare me because i'm going to smack
you upside the head that's my response
i don't flinch my response is to go
forward
and you know my father ingrained that in
me
then i got in the seal teams and that
was ingrained in me
and that night in that gunfight it was
there was no thoughts that was all
reaction that was all muscle memory
uh i was terrified i went through a
terrified a little bit of terror
terrification that's a new word
and uh once i got past that i was just
angry
and then everything was automatic
you go on um
you go on here in the book my parents
divorced not long after my father broke
my mother's arm my mother would
soon start dating and eventually marry
tom a black man
a rare union in the 1970s my father held
racist beliefs in my mother's marriage
to a black man inflamed my father's
racist sentiment
the divorce included a custody hearing i
was young but i can distinctly recall
someone in court a lawyer possibly the
judge
asking me strange questions about tom
like have you ever seen tom naked have
you ever seen
tom and your mother sleeping together
the focus of the custody battle which
should have been my father and his
treatment of
us was instead trained on me an innocent
bystander
interracial relationships were not the
social norm
in the 1970s i'm sure the court knew my
father beat my mother
and us kids but they still awarded him
full
custody regardless my hunch is that the
course were so
biased at the time that they decided my
younger brother and i would be better
off
with a wife beater and abusive father
than be raised by an interracial couple
all speculation but i mean the 70s were
kind of like that
yeah where was this uh this was uh
new jersey still in new jersey and
they're still married and i got two
brothers
one one's in the coast guard from that
marriage
and uh he's a rescue swimmer well not a
rescuer he's
a crew chief on the birds that go out
that carry the rescue swimmers so how
old are you at this point
you must been six years old or something
like that uh
yeah right about then about six i'm
thinking um
you know when i when i picture you i
don't picture the
the old bastard that i see in front of
me right now i picture this young
kid with blonde hair
and you know blue eyes there's a picture
of me in there yeah yeah no
that's that's when i opened i was like
oh yeah i know this guy
um not this one yeah
so i'm sure you're looking at me
thinking the same thing you know my dad
was driving around as well we haven't
changed that much
really if i shave this yeah yeah no you
did you you don't look that much
different except for you you used to
have the freaking uh
the blonde locks bright blonde blocks i
do miss them
no but i'm thinking you know you're
there you are in court this little
aryan kid and the judges are looking at
you know the
the interracial couple and like you said
the i mean you said it's a what'd you
say it's an assumption
but to think of any other reason
why they would decide to send you with a
known
child abuser is it's hard to come up
with a different reason
well that's another reason why this
book's really good i don't think anybody
be able to pick that up nobody gets this
life without trauma
and uh it's a lot more prevalent than i
think we understand
child abuse and you look at the child
trafficking
going on right now uh i mean
they're just some really bad parents
really bad people out there
and people are going to suffer trauma
you got to build the resiliency it's
training
they helped us build the resiliency we
required to do what we did
in the seal teams and it's just training
if you sit on the couch and eat twinkies
all day
and watch and watch tv anytime something
other than that comes up that causes
stress you're just not gonna be able to
handle it you gotta train
to be able to handle stress yeah and
then i mean
the you know that sounds awesome
that sounds awesome but the reality is i
mean you're probably
this small percentage of people that can
get out of a situation like this and
move in in a positive direction i don't
know what the percentage is but
obviously there's some percentage of
people that
go through these traumatic experiences
as kids and they end up
you know they end up in jail on drugs
and whatever else and
um yeah i mean there's there's something
along the way that made you
there's not a whole lot of difference
between me and 80 of prisoners here in
california
i just had the
proper opportunity at the right time
mm-hmm
because if i didn't join the navy yeah i
might be i i
i'd be wrong with ms-13 yeah i'm gonna
come after
the amount of seals and this sounds
freaking horrible to say look there's
some guys that are saints in the seal
teams for sure
but the amount of guys in the seal teams
just if you just took a broad
cut of the seal mentality there is
an element of the criminal mentality in
there
like oh the if you if you want to join
the navy we we know where this is going
to end up
for sure well we have to deal with
criminals
yeah yes i mean a lot of people think
that when we go to war
i'd venture to say that 75 percent of
the people that we're dealing with
are are not isis or al qaeda they're
just the
criminal element that are profit
profiteers off of
off of the current i mean look what we
got going on
whatever mayhem is going on yeah they
theologically they don't they don't care
they're just like hey i can make some
money off of that yeah
looking at the religion in this country
you know we've got how many christians
and then what level are they practicing
you know it's the same thing with
muslims
yeah they're muslim but are they really
practicing
are they really going to follow what
they think is right
or are they going to take the path of
least resistance which is what humans
will do
you you continue on here fast forward a
little bit my father was a sailor when
the navy issued him new orders we moved
to pennsylvania from new jersey after
the divorce my father remarried our new
stepmother soon became pregnant giving
birth to my first half sister two years
later
she gave birth to my half brother trauma
attracts trauma
it has its own distinct language and
behaviors we would be raised by two
people who'd been severely traumatized
as children
my new stepmother was a natural fit for
our family she too had a history
of childhood abuse both physical and
mental
i don't know much about her the early
years of her life other than her parents
would lock her in a closet for long
periods of time
she was put up for adoption and taken in
by a loving couple my stepmother would
grow up to
be both victim and perpetrator she would
alternate between
coercing my father to beat us and
slapping us around herself
she and my father would get into their
own fights too she would fight back
even though she had no way of winning he
was six foot two and weighed 240 pounds
one of the worst beatings i ever endured
was when
i was eight my brother and i had gone
out on a winter day and pelted a car
with snowballs the driver was pissed is
it but if he'd known the price we were
about to pay for our transgressions
he may have given us a pass we ran to
our house with the driver of the car
chasing us
he knocked on our front door and told my
parents what we had done
my father and stepmother had a friend
over at the time they were all drinking
my parents were outraged
our father sent us to the basement an ad
hoc torture chamber of sorts
where he made us strip naked before
tying our hands to a pole so we were
facing each other
he whipped us with his belt so hard
after another 15 minutes we'd worked up
he'd worked up a sweat all the while my
stepmother and her friend sat on the
basement steps sipping their booze
urging him to beat us harder and longer
when he was done my brother and i were
both
badly bloodied and bruised
my father's violence escalated as we
grew he would smear toothpaste on the
nylon belt
when he whipped us so it would sting as
it cut and bruised us
i'm not sure where he picked up this
technique but it worked
his routine was to bring me into the
basement and make me drop my pants so
that my bare ass was available he would
wind up and rip into my
bare backside with that belt holding
onto my arm as i twisted in a circle
trying to escape
i recall a week that was prefaced with
him telling us
i know that you will be bad kids this
week
he beat us bloody and then he went back
to work
this was some crazy stuff he was so nuts
he set his alarm for 4 am to wake us up
and beat us for no reason whatsoever
before he went to work
we got beat and we went back to bed
hardly a typical morning routine for a
first grader
my childhood was a real life horror
movie i couldn't escape was terrible
about that a lot of people have
worse
i got out of it a lot of people don't
yeah um
where this ends up you say finally at
the age of 12 after years of enduring
its drunken rages and
endless beatings i decided to fight back
one night i found him passed out drunk
on the couch i knew
that he was passed out because the
crotch of his blue jeans was darkened
from having wet himself
i grabbed a baseball bat and walked back
and forth for about five minutes
debating my intentions until finally i
mustered up my courage
and with an overhead axe swing i drilled
him hard on the chest with the baseball
bat
it felt great a totally empowering rush
i didn't kill him but i sure surprised
him
because he immediately woke up from his
booze-induced blackout with a look of
total confusion
that quickly turned evil he looked at
the bat in my hands and realized that i
was would
that that was what just bounced out off
his chest i knew by the look in his eyes
he was going to kill me
he chased me upstairs to my room where i
jumped out of my second story window
into a thorny rose bush i looked up to
see my enraged father stick his head out
only to pull it back in i could hear his
pounding footsteps from outside as he
ran downstairs
he was determined to hunt me down
chasing me through the woods around
our house in the dark he couldn't get
through the thick underbrush but i was
too
terrified to slow down he never caught
me i spent the night at a neighbor's
house and the next day when i returned
home he had forgotten all about it
in 1983 my father was transferred to
miramar near san diego california that's
where he totally lost it
he was drinking causing problems at work
had been arrested several times for
defeat defecating
in the aisles of stores
some mental health professionals
describe this peculiar public display as
elimination disorder it's a behavior
that's been identified in several serial
killers and manifest
out of extreme anger at someone or
something
i was 12 years old when my stepmother
received word that my father would be
medically discharged from the navy
and institutionalized with schizophrenia
and a host of other psychiatric
conditions
he would spend the rest of his life in
an inpatient facility or an assisted
living environment
my father has since died he was very
sick and really broken he did a terrible
job as a parent however
i know now that he did his best that he
did the best he could
i don't hold any harsh feelings toward
him
he really sucked as a father
dang so i mean it's just
it's beyond he had like legitimate
serious mental issues
well his father was worse than him
uh he just wasn't the one that was able
to break the cycle
i think he tried to it just ate him up
i mean his father used to chase hit him
his his brother and his sister
around with butcher knives and
threatened to kill him he never actually
threatened to kill us
i mean with that that thought's always
there
his father used to actually make that
threat i never i never met my
grandfather
and what was your grandfather already
dead or was
quite honestly i don't know if they just
kept us from him or
or if he was or if he had passed i met
his mother
you know looking back on that as a kid
it was strange she was she was broke
just a broken uh
broken woman just strange you know
just not normal i mean
go over thanksgiving dinner and
everybody's eating kentucky fried
chicken
which i don't complain about it i mean
you got you got food but uh
not gonna complain with having food but
it was just
it was not a normal atmosphere you could
just feel that it was weird
i mean his sister grew up in a
psychiatric ward
she went in when she was really early
really young
so i don't know what kind of what was
done to her so i mean
some serious darkness there
i mean we got that going on now in the
world it's pretty prevalent you know
just shitty parents that
abuse their kids don't know how to be
parents because they were abused
uh it's really not an excuse i mean my
kids tell me
well i've got old kids i've got a 20
year old and 29 year old
and they've always told me we wish he
would spank us rather than yell at us
i was like it's because you've never
been smacked you might change your mind
if you've got
got an asshole
you go on here i was about 12 or 13
years old when my stepmother became our
legal guardian and seized her new found
freedom by dating a guy in a local
in a local rock and roll band named
beachy
and hosting parties at our house our
home quickly turned into a constant
party
with its own in-house band and all the
characters that came with it
people strangers would sit around my
house all day getting drunk and stoned
on one particular occasion my stepmother
was partying with beechy and his band of
losers when she tried to smack me i
caught her arms spun it behind her back
then
swept the legs out from under dumping
her on her ass
that episode got me and my brother sent
to maine to live with
our maternal grandparents who we hadn't
seen in years
for that summer my half siblings were
still young at the time i still remember
looking over my shoulder and seeing my
half brother lying in his crib and my
half sister lying in her bed
as i made my way out of the house
that is the funny thing about trauma
because that's the only thing i remember
those two
i mean i talked to him now but it's as
if
they weren't even in the same house with
us
i don't remember them were they getting
any different treatment
uh i don't remember them that's wild and
so
and you were like i don't know you were
what team were you at two i was a team
two
was it team one team two team my brother
did like eight years at team two
from when to win uh
god sometime after two thousand ten
what does that mean what you're doing i
was going i got out in 2010. yeah i
retired in 2010.
um yeah the usc was in teams for like 10
years
that's awesome but just no memory of
them of them
none at all that's so wow the only thing
i can remember is
looking over my shoulder when i was
walking out of the house now i can tell
this is what i think
about memories uh
like i don't go back to the town where i
grew up very often
and so i don't because i don't like fi
when i say very often i mean
for 10 years at a time right and i don't
see all those people that i kind of grew
up with
so i don't fire those
right i don't fire those memories very
often so they just like fade
and i'll go back there and see someone
like oh yeah i remember when you did
this all i remember remember that girl
remember this and this thing over here
and i'm always like i i feel bad
because they're telling me vivid stories
about my own childhood and i just don't
remember and i think it's because i just
don't
didn't fire those you can read studies
on people's memories especially in
stressful situations
and like like i said my citation is not
accurate
they gave me credit for saving six women
and children that were supposedly in the
same room that was in
a gun fight with four dudes with
automatic weapons they'd all be dead
the guy that saw that looked past one of
our guys that had been shot and killed
to see the six women and children in a
totally different room didn't even see
the guy laying in the doorway he just
saw the six women and children and
superimposed them in the room that i was
in they'd all be dead
hundreds and hundreds of rounds were
fired in that room
in a matter of minutes
so now you're heading up to maine that
fall my brother and i moved to maine
from virginia beach to live with our
mother and her second husband tom it was
only after we arrived that i learned
about how my stepmother and father
deliberately and systematically tried to
alienate me and my brother from our
mother
she showed us a box filled with years
worth of christmas and birthday cards
had been returned without the check
she'd written for us my
father and stepmother cast them all and
kept the money for themselves
despite this i feel the same about my
stepmother as i do about my father she
survived my father's violence and did
the best she could
i don't hold any harsh feelings towards
her either
tom and my mother never hit us they were
patient did their best to parent some
severely abused young minds
if the courts hadn't been so biased we
could have skipped the seven years of
abuse and lived in virginia beach all
along
but as i would learn everything happens
for a reason
never made it through buds
i made it through eighth grade and
entered green run high school where i
lasted until my
junior year when my wrestling coach
caught me smoking pop in the
school bathroom this caused my exposure
was that a public school green run
yeah it's hard to get kicked out of that
one
it's actually it was actually called
gang run
it's hard to get kicked out of that one
shortly after being expelled i had to
run in with the police
cop busting me with a bag of weed at the
time any amount over an ounce was a
felony the cop grabbed the bag and said
is this an ounce i said yes he opened
the bag
grabbed a pinch and chucked it onto the
street then said is this announced now
no i replied that cop saved me from a
felony charge and may have even saved my
life
i'd like to find that guy one day and
thank him there's a good cop
trying to take care of this freaking
knucklehead kid i was like 14 or 15
years god
so from so you came down i spent almost
30 days in jail now
that's where i learned how to play uh
what was it pinocchio
learned how to play a bunch of card
games oh man so then you end up spades i
learned how to play
spades that comes in that comes in handy
on the on the ships
once you're in the navy um you ended up
in the job corps which is like you know
you're doing vocational training
uh that doesn't seem to work out too
great
1990 or 1988 you got a neighbor retired
navy dire
diver who tells you you're gonna end up
dead or in jail if you keep this up
you should join the seal teams instead
they'll pay you to do all the things
you're doing to get in trouble right now
he was
he was giving good advice maybe he
totally saw it
he totally saw his kids were crazier
than me yeah
man you know there's that attraction of
violence man
and just mayhem when you're a kid well
it wasn't
violence it was just you know tying
ropes in
one tree and blowing another one and
sliding down on handlebars and just
jumping over ridiculous jumps on our
bikes you know smashing frames on our
bikes and
just stuff i won't admit to and
so uh you you you head down and you're
gonna join the marines
i did i tried to and then you got
rejected by the marine corps for
having a ged and i actually met a guy
that was a recruiter back then
that was in 88 or 89 and
they had a restriction you had to have a
high school diploma the ged wouldn't get
you in
which i'm my guardian angels
knew i'd have done four years in the
marine corps i already got out yeah
i couldn't have done that there's no way
i could have done that
yeah i mean i like working with them but
pre-9 11
marine corps was a lot different yeah
yeah we didn't get along too well pretty
911. yeah that's um
the marine corps is a completely
different environment yeah and
and i mean they do what they do
it's actually more it's more dangerous
than what we do yeah and their
day-to-day life freaking uh uh
more spartan life you know especially if
you're an infantryman like that's
patrol to contact yeah go get some wait
till someone shoots you
it's gonna go get them it sucks i like
to wait till they're asleep
that's the goal um
you wrap up here saying my childhood was
not exactly idyllic but
it's what happened to me and i'm very
grateful for all of it the wounds of my
childhood trauma served as the
foundation
of some truly excellent resiliency
training that's a very positive way of
looking at this mic
resiliency is a conditioned response to
physical and emotional trauma and stress
it's
a never ending process of understanding
endurance evaluation acceptance
and application that continues to help
me get through some very difficult
situations
childhood trauma especially the kind
perpetrated by parents can be some of
the most damaging
because it can cause children to feel
unlovable some children who feel
unlovable can become
unlovable adults and some of those
become
unlovable parents thus repeating the
cycle the unlovable live
lonely tragic lives if my hurts mistakes
butt whippings and insights can help you
overcome yours then this book has value
for both of us
hey i'm not the only one with mommy and
daddy issues
jack uh yeah i got some i got some
codependency shit going on
you know i tell people uh i mean we all
got insecurities
you know i caught navy seals got
insecurities it's one of the most
insecure people i know are navy seals
they're like trying so damn hard yeah
yeah yeah i always can't let anybody
know i'm weak here
i always laugh in the teams if someone
says hey you know mike mike day's really
good at uh parachuting
someone will chime in the back yeah but
he's a slow runner you know
yeah but exactly but somebody's gonna
let you know yeah but running breeds
cowardice
so always a bunch of cowards
uh and so now you go to boot camp to
buds after signing on the dotted line i
spent the next six months working out
doing my best not to get in trouble
until i finally boarded the
bus for maps and facility in southern
virginia
masses the way station for all new
military recruits there i found
myself part of an interesting blend of
americana one that included all shape
sizes colors and temperatures of young
men and women who are leaving for the
civil leaving the civilian world
getting the first taste of the us
military you know what that's inaccuracy
because i went to great lakes
yeah well there are women i did have a
writer with me i missed that one that
was all dudes up there
all the women were going to orlando what
about maps yeah maps was even even
even at maps uh at maps yeah they were
sending
all the women at the time to orlando
everybody goes to great lakes now that
place sucks what is meps i heard that
before
military military entry processing
station
so you you actually enlist and
you wait a period of time before you go
because they just snatch you so you
don't go out
like do something else they don't
actually have you know what kind of
situation well
you're not under any kind of restriction
or any kind of order or
under the the ucmj yet you've signed a
contract
and they give you a date that you're
going to leave so i was only on
in maps for like six months i've talked
to kids that been
you know 18 months they
hit some kid in high school you know
waiting for him to graduate get him
young
i was 17 years old when i joined i
didn't get anywhere else to go
uh this one i found this funny and this
is also probably why
you say that the marine corps wouldn't
have worked out great for you over a
long period of time it's
you say i never in my life wanted to
quit anything more than i did
navy boot camp miserable
yeah bro yeah uh
i mean there's golden underwear oh and
great lakes too
january oh january 4th uh five feet of
snow
30 below man i hate the cold weather
yeah i'd rather sweat um
you end up you said i think the company
commander saw some potential me
and knew that i was bored because i kept
volunteering to wake up at 4am to do
what most people dreaded they decided to
give me some extra responsibility made
me divisions
recruit the divisions recruit mastered
arms
i was like you're for when i was going
through boot camp i got made like a
squad leader or something i got fired
from that one oh bomber
okay well i talked about that in the
book the guy wiped the booger on my
pillow and
right as the company commander was
walking in the door i punched him yeah
and so that so you got rolled back from
graduation week
of boot camp and then i get well i got
rolled
out of in buds out of 166 in the 168 and
i got rolled graduation week
of 168. just the irony of that
then you they both made me cry before
you before you went to so you got rolled
back in
in um in boot camp which i didn't even
know there was such a thing as getting
rolled back
it was only one week though which was
cool oh that's right because because
you go to great lakes or i went to
orlando but you still have to do that
stupid passing review all that margin
yeah garbage
yeah well nobody was coming to visit me
for graduation i got into that fight
because you put a booger on my pillow
i did knock him out i knocked that kid
out well he was not a kid
i was a kid he was a lot older than me
and uh
so i didn't have to do the passing
review they just made me like a parking
lot attendant
i didn't want to do it anyway yeah all
that practice
yeah and we were in a nazi company too
they
all the flags remember those stupid
flags for i don't even remember what
they were for
bro i actually best marchers best you
fold your underwear the best
yeah this is not like i have very
limited memories of boot camp
i hated it yeah i know that i hated it
but i don't remember a lot about i
remember like the highlights of it
probably the biggest i remember just you
don't remember shoveling snow
no i definitely don't remember orlando i
remember sweating i remember like
sweating big giant pools of sweat i
don't know how to go in there
i remember the space shuttle took off
while we were standing out there like
there was a space shuttle launch and
that's totally cool i was like oh that's
cool but don't remember much from boot
camp
uh so you go from there to see school
and then you get
orders get orders to go to the uss carl
vinson
yeah which is my first set of orders
were to
the carl vinson via nuke c school
c new machinist mate c school
so basically for everyone that doesn't
know that means hello regular navy no
no no buds no seal teams and i got to
watch those guys go through school there
that was at the same place i was going
through a school
they were a bunch of zombies like 12
hours of class oh
it's free i had a night class and they
had a morning class
i don't want a nuke yeah that's that's a
freaking hard job man
it's a freaking hard job i got kicked
out of high school they wanted me to be
a nuke yeah
whoever was running your career
consulting was not doing a great job
dude they should have bee lined you
straight to the
freaking buds uh but then you did you
this is kind of crazy though you like
requested captain's mass
no i just went to his office so you
didn't even
so that's even better you didn't even
request captain as you said i'm going to
go talk to the old man
yeah kind of like you know group two you
know what was her name that was up there
for like longer than anybody was in the
seal teams the secretary yeah yeah
so i talked to the secretary and i was
like i got a problem with my orders i
had my orders
and uh i don't know how i got in there
but she let me get in there
and i think the guy was just amazed at
some e2 was coming to his office
some boot i'm like real boot that's
insane dude
and i told him hey look i passed the
test for the screening test for buds
there was 50 of us only like
10 of us passed i was told i was going
to get this on my on my contract and
this is what i got
he was like do you understand that
you're not supposed to be doing it this
way that's kind of how the conference
i was like i kind of played
in between i knew it was wrong but i
didn't care
because there was no way i was going to
nuke c school
so whatever i had to do i was going to i
was going to do it and then the dude was
cool and just said all right and he took
care of it
i got beat a little bit but i'm beat
not like buds i mean do you ever try to
count how many push-ups you did in one
day in buds
no no you get up to a thousand did you
ever i tried
really you don't need to lose count yeah
i never even thought about
the twin 82's hitting or 72's hit in the
back of the head
forget what number you're on
i drove the chow once and this guy
didn't make it through he was such a big
teddy bear crews
just couldn't run and we were late for
chow
and i had a volkswagen beetle i was like
oh we'll go get ciao
so last was already gone so so so now
we're fast forwarding the buds we're
jumping in the buzzer this is this first
phase
no it's cool man so this is first phase
this was
i can't even remember so the brakes went
out on the thing
and you know across the cross
intersection at 75
yeah so i crash into that thing because
my brakes go out
i only hit it at like 25 30 miles an
hour both of us hit the windshield
started the windshield windshield's out
in the middle of 75 as the buds class
and the instructors drive by us and like
oh god
fifteen hundred eight count bodybuilders
that weekend that weekend both of us
we cheated yeah you pay for it and
yeah sometimes you can't buy threes
sometimes you can't buy fives
you can't do fifteen hundred dollars
did you just stand out on the first
phase outside the first phase office or
something and just sit there and do the
bill
yeah it was first safe yeah it was right
by the bell how do you remember
was it like did you do like 750 a day or
something like that
uh no we just when nobody was looking we
just
counted sometimes they sat in front of
us we count by once
as soon as they left we're like 505.
did you have any idea what you were
getting into when you went to buds
uh like what comprehension level did you
had i basically
yeah i i heard it was gonna be hard
um and that's kind of a mindset i've
always
i've always gotten out and it works i
don't know if it worked for other people
but i always think it's gonna be worse
than it really is
so a lot of times it's just hard to get
started
like how good of a we i know you only
were in high school for a couple years
but but how good of a how great well did
you i know you wrestled
i played football i wrestled when i grew
up i
played all sports soccer i boxed a
little bit uh
hence the knockouts yeah i remember
almost knocking myself out playing
football
i was always vicious just getting after
it
i played basketball never really scored
a point my coach would just say go foul
that guy that was me
so so but you had so you had you had
some good athletic background
yeah i liked playing sports yeah so you
would but you had no knowledge of buds
like hey
none at all did you do did you did you
think about
like i was i always talk about you know
when i was quote getting ready for buds
no idea what to expect i just knew that
you ran a lot and you swam a lot so i
ran a lot i swam a lot
but i would do you know four
sets of pull-ups and be like all right
you know that was a good workout and
just had no
idea that you were gonna get the buds
and you were gonna do
hundreds of pull-ups in an hour like
more than you could count well they do
don't expect you to
be able to turn a 14-mile run when you
show up yeah
it is progressive yeah i think they're
even getting smarter about it now
they're definitely getting smarter about
it but um
and guys are the guys are getting
smarter about it i guess that's my point
people abuse it too what do you mean you
can only keep me in the water for 10
minutes because
58 degrees they know that when do you
think that chart
became a thing uh after us
are you being serious like do you think
it is after us because i it is after us
yeah i mean they were just it was no
freaking rules like they
probably looked at the student body as a
curve
and if somebody wanted hypothermia okay
it might need to take them out now
i remember that part i remember them
walking down the line and being like
you could hear them like hey brother
because the smarties they shut the
flashlight
this guy's getting high pain and but if
no if you didn't hear that then it's
like back in the water
and they would just keep you doing that
until someone started getting
hypothermia
maybe two people started getting
hypothermia and then they'd be like on
to the next evolution there wasn't no
graph that they were following
no i think they they do now i mean i
think it's good there's good and bad to
it
uh i wish the students didn't know it
that's part of the game not knowing so
and you also met your wife
while you were in fourth phase so the
old fourth phase was you were there
basically standing by to class up i
don't know i don't know what they call
it now
fourth phase i think it's still called
fourth phase so you were you were there
which is weird
yeah okay and that's when you you you
met your future
wife um
and then rolling into first phase
drown proofing
um you call rescue swimmer life saving
yeah so i did work with the writers so
some of the stuff
is has changed a little bit uh the whole
process of going with this
what is that award program uh
that you got to use when you're editing
sometimes some things just get by like
man i can't figure this program
yeah it's uh it plus when you look at
something over and over again you're
just gonna miss stuff it happens well
and when you work with a civilian
stuff that they think is interesting is
i'm like why do you want to talk about
this jack
so it was there was something that the
guy i worked with uh felt was
interesting and
didn't get the proper terminology
because to me drown proofing was
we didn't lose many people to that yeah
drown proofing john proofing was pretty
easy
you know we lost a few guys yeah he was
a few guys in not tying lose a few guys
in
order swim the underwater swim we did
lose a few guys in
life saving because life saving was
interesting
because it was a subjective thing where
they could look at a guy and be like hey
this guy we don't like they're just
trying to drown you yeah and then
they're gonna drown you and you they
don't like you
because they have that power um to
do the whole waste push and go down
there and tug on their shit and make
them
comply it's a scrap
for sure it is i mean that's what they
say you don't let them grab on to you
you got to get them away from you and
sometimes you got to hurt them but man
good punch to the gut you know they'll
calm them down they definitely
they're going to live there were some
guys that they just weren't going to
make it
you know like a guy that they didn't
like or whatever had a bad attitude or
they thought it was a punk
he wasn't going to get out of the water
well those people have a history too
it's not just one evolution it's a yeah
the repetitive
poor performance yeah i think that it
seems like there's
you think they're stricter about that
now where there's less subjectivity
or do you think it's the same well i
would just have to say that
i know there's some things that have
changed and a lot of guys will be like
oh i think buds is easier
but the attrition rate's the same yeah
so they're not making any more seals no
i mean
even with a class that's twice the size
i mean we would start with like 125 guys
to get 20.
now they're starting with what 200
something yeah one i think they start
with 165 and they still get whatever
whatever they're still only 10 of that
is yeah they're still only getting that
it's still 75 80 percent of attrition
so it's still i don't think it's any
easier than it used to be
no i i down there i talked to friends
that are down there they're like no it's
not not easier the other thing that's
like one of the evolution might be
different that's
like for instance when when i went
through we had twin 72s
they're not as buoyant as the twin 80s
so it was a little bit harder to tread
water yeah with those damn tanks
because they're steel and they weren't
as buoyant you know what else they wear
um like lightweight boots now
not jungle boots not old-school jungle
boats that was a difference to that when
i was going through is
everything was in boots yep they were
getting ready to transition to the shoes
so the times were different and almost
didn't
translate you know going from boots and
then lowering the times because you're
in sneakers
it was almost hard yeah i just know we
wore boots
and then when i eventually picked up
what they started wearing i was like oh
that's way nicer yeah they were issuing
this those garbage new balance which
gave me shin splints oh just the running
shoes yeah
like when you
they didn't my legs were better off in
boots
than running in sneakers the sneakers
hurt me more
so that's what a 710 pace that's not bad
and boots yeah but the thing that's the
other thing that's
uh what is it deceiving the thing that's
deceiving about buds is they go hey it's
only a
a 32 minute four mile time run that's an
eight minute mile when you first get
there you go oh that's
what i can do no problem yeah but you
just did a two-mile swim this morning
you just did a two-mile swim and then
you did it and then it's
five miles just five miles to go to ciao
three times a day
yeah you run five miles every day just
to eat yeah and not to mention that four
mile timed run
ain't four miles i don't know what they
do now but i know that there was times
where i'd run as hard as i could and i
wouldn't be able to
i'd be like barely passing well they do
that to every class
they have that one run that's long so
everybody fails
it's a mind game psychological we were
doing the five mile time run and that
extra mile
was so much harder exponentially just
to put out for that much longer just one
mile yeah
and they actually had to get rid of that
because it was injuring people and a lot
of people were failing it
crazy that's what they were pinging me
on trying to get me kicked out
but i brought a watch i was passing it
yeah so so how did that happen
you so so you brought a watch because
that's another thing that's hard is you
don't know
we're not allowed to have a watch and we
were running the edts so you're
what phase is this do you remember this
is third phase uh
which was dive phase back then um
and so you failed one run uh he was
failing me on all of them and everybody
behind me okay so you had a beef with an
instructor
with uh and we're not gonna mention
names but he was the phase officer he
was okay
live phase officer and uh
oh you know you know the game that used
to be played during room inspections
i mean you're gonna fail you're gonna
get wet and sandy and he
he was in front of me and he was like
why do you have all this stolen
equipment in your locker and oh my god
i don't know what you're talking about
so he's talking about like extra knives
uts and co2s garbage right
and i was like i don't have any of that
stuff in my locker i was just up there
and the conversation just got to the
point where he was like well one of two
things has happened you're lying or i'm
lying i was like well it's not me so it
must be you
but it wasn't like a disrespectful thing
i was answering a damn question
i was just answering his question he
said one of one of two things is
happening
what is it i was like well it's not me
it must be you
damn e2 to a narcissistic
lieutenant yeah at the time that's
freaking crazy
you had like you had more balls than me
going through buds
i wasn't balls i was just answering a
question i don't know man i don't know
if i would have said
it hate me i guess it depends on how you
said it too
it was not coming from a place of
disrespect it was i was just totally
answering the damn question you're just
like i'm not lying
i'm not lying it's you you asked i'm
answering your questions
so he didn't like that and so now he
kind of had it out for you and then he
sicked
that guy we were talking about earlier
on me so he started
just harassing me you know third phase
was a lot of classroom
you know dive physics and all that
garbage
but every break i was getting wet and
sandy doing
pull-ups doing push-ups he was just
beating me up and then he started
failing me on the runs
and i talked about in the book i think i
actually named him the guy named doc
flynn
oh yeah i went and told him i was like
hey look i brought a watch they're
failing me
i mean i'm passing these things by like
two minutes and they're failing me and
everybody behind me
that's kind of a weird move because you
were breaking the rules
well i had to yeah i know but that's a
weird move man that's a weird move to
because i've always done it though yeah
i went and talked to the commanding
officer yeah dude
like i said you got more balls than i
had i just didn't know any different
yeah i wasn't doing it because
i thought it was having balls it was
just i don't know how else to get out of
this
fix this so you're not allowed to bring
a watch and you brought a watch you
timed yourself yeah i timed it
i tied it to the uh you remember that
the buckles on the edt's yeah i tied it
to a piece of
like 550 cord and hung it down there
cool and so you pan how did you how did
you single out doc flynn
as the guy that you would trust uh he
was just
one of the guys in the phase that really
never beat us up for no reason
he seemed like a fair dude yeah i mean
there was two kinds of instructors there
there was guys hiding out
that never really did anything and then
there was guys that
back in those days too there wasn't a
whole lot going on but guys that were
operational that just needed a break
so you know some of them just beat us up
just because
they thought they were the gatekeepers
you know kind of like going to some of
these army schools
i'm the gatekeeper we have to have an
attrition rate
and i'm going to make sure you go
through something as hard as i used to
or i did because their fish story is
buds was a lot harder when i went
through
and this guy this guy was a skinny
little punk but
he later got administratively separated
uh for something else he'd done so
karma's a bitch
yeah so then but doc flynn was like all
right cool
and then he ran the next run and he said
i'm gonna run i'll run the pace
and if you finish in front of me you
pass doc flynn legit
so he ran it and this was a five mile
time run
which they got rid of uh they came
across the finish line and you know what
happens
when you're the cutoff guy how many
times can you be the cutoff guy
every damn time yeah no that's uh
one of my lpos who you know um people
you know when i used my first lpo and i
was like
coming out of buds i'm asking him bud's
questions like did you ever were you
ever in the goon squad and he goes i was
the cut off for the good squad he said
every single run he was
unlike the moon
that was the only time i got into the
goon squad two the whole time through
buds
was on those times runs and uh
what i was good at was winning that
first race so you could get secured from
the goons coin yeah
so then so then what happened uh well
he came across the finish line and when
you're cut off for the goon squad you
get sent
to the water that's where you wind up
when you fail that run he comes across
you know a couple minutes after we
finished and we're getting hammered
and he was like what's going on with
those guys and he was like well they all
failed
and flynn was like i just did it i just
passed it
they're like two minutes in front of me
but it it got hidden because i went to a
uh
a review board and still got rolled back
dang
i got rolled back uh that was graduation
week
and i got rolled back to drag her face
at least i didn't have to do the open
circuit garbage again yeah and this was
when this was when die phase was
third phase when i went through a year
or two later
dive phase was second phase because they
still get rid of a lot of guys during
dive phase yes
to me i thought it was the hardest phase
dive phase yeah
yeah i think i think that's why they
moved it to that well we lost more
people there
you don't lose people online warfare
yeah
yeah you got to be pretty stupid dude i
think we lost two guys
yeah one of the guys was a good dude i
think he did something that they didn't
like
and they got rid of them he was an
officer too personality
yeah that'll happen crazy
that's a pretty critical community
that self-regulates though it works
indeed uh
and then where are you at sqt did you go
through
you went through stt right well it was
it was kind of a weird one it wasn't
uh sqt like it is now
it was kind of thrown together at the
team because you went to team three yeah
but they
they cooperated with the other teams so
i went through
whatever they call i think it was called
stt at the time
and uh it was just because we had
training sales at each of the teams and
they would run it
yeah so we were meshed together with
team one three five
and it was kind of ad hoc and then they
jammed us into platoons and the platoons
pretty much took care of us
we didn't have our tridents back then
either guys show up at the teams now
with the tridents and
um we actually had a different nec when
we what was it 53 2020
yeah and then it was up to your platoon
to decide when you got it
they started giving the guys tridents in
sqt so they'd show up to the team
guys were taking the new guys that
showed up with their tridents and making
them
painting them blue
but they still kind of kept it the
tradition uh like you can go back into
platoon huts now now
the platoons with the new guys like you
don't get your trident even though it's
been put in your admin record
we're not going to give it to you until
we say it's and then they'll have like
the fish tank or
you've seen one of those pac-man frogs
i've seen a pac-man frog with all the
tridents in it and they got to keep the
frog alive oh that's legit
it's a it's a fun community yeah and
there's
you know you talk about some of the fun
in the community best college i ever
went to
yeah um some of the fun of the community
which is called hazing
zero tolerance it never happens yeah uh
yeah um i see that's a good
good thing about hazing uh especially
well probably
now also i know there's a zero tolerance
and it doesn't happen but
if you don't get hazed they don't like
you they don't trust you
yeah so if you get haste you're like
okay this guy's all right
so it's like a privilege thank you sir
can i have another
there ain't enough of you to hurt me uh
not enough of you
one of the things you said here is
you're getting your bird and um
this all sounded good i just this
brought back memories
uh the the commanding officer was the
last guy to pound in my trident he had a
big grin on his face as he approached he
pulled the trident out of my body
because
this is after you when you get you're
trying to you know well we still have
quarters
too yeah headquarters you get your
trident and then the
the first you know
i don't know who pain that's awesome i
think it was my platoon commander
but though anyways the whole team
freaking lines up and pounds that thing
into your chest
you know the that doesn't hurt yeah i
mean
well okay maybe it didn't hurt you air
me i mean i mean the punch but you don't
actually feel the prongs after yes you
don't feel the prongs after the first
eight
you know you're bleeding but then but
then
guys start pulling it out and like oh
it's a little crooked jocko
and they get you again that hurts worse
but what i like yeah it's got like those
little nubs on the end of it oh
the little widgets attached to yeah when
you pull it out you could feel it
pulling your yep you feel your chest
coming out
uh but you say your commanding officer
he pulled the trident out of my body
straightened it like he was fixing
a bent nail then he placed it on my
chest and slowly pushed it back in
that hurts worse i was gonna say that's
freaking good times from the old man
right there
that's back in the days where the back
40 was uh
where attitude adjustments were made
yeah
uh now you're going on peacetime
deployment you say this my peacetime
deployments took me around the globe
asia middle east egypt kuwait japan
korea guam
points beyond in between conducting
joint country to country training on my
deployment to bahrain we patrolled the
persian gulf and forcing
oil embargoes we would board oil tankers
that were in violation of various
infractions most of the time the
infraction was that they didn't identify
themselves because the radio didn't work
we would catch churches we would catch
tankers bearing the iranian flag
filled with embargoed iraqi oil all
sorts of shenanigans going on
um so would you do four deployments
eight
what'd you do in that first run at team
three
four four and the first one was
southeast asia that was like
right after the gulf war uh would you go
to the pi
i went to the pi yeah so then i think
your war happened so fast
we couldn't get there then you end up
your it looked like you were going to go
to buds and be an instructor
yeah but you actually had orders you had
orders to buds and then what what how
did you how did you
hear about the leap frog tryout i was
just by chance uh
and i only had like 30 35 jumps that's
insane i had no idea what i was doing
that's insane i mean those guys at that
time had thousands of jumps
well there was there were some guys on
on that team that had
uh what was that program we used to have
our own well we still do
the the original free fall program that
we had just the military free-fall that
was out
like three something 3m 3t i can't
remember what it was
but it was our own program out there at
uh
yeah you know so a lot of those
instructors were
on the team with me dwight settle andy
krauthammel uh-huh
you know glade jackson they all had a
couple thousand players yeah those are
the guys i'm talking about like they
were freaking i had 30.
so you decided hey what the hell i'll go
get a bunch of jumps in i had no idea
right yeah i was i think i got like 45
jumps
tryouts with the cool parachute and then
you ended up making it
yeah that was freaking crazy clay told
me he could teach a monkey to fall out
of an airplane if he had enough bananas
that was his because i didn't think i
was going to make it i thought i was
going to buzz
and i really didn't want to the jump
team was
was some of the most fun i had probably
one of the most dangerous jobs i had
until
combat yeah the jump team at that time
man they were pushing the envelope
hardcore
yeah we had some injuries uh we had we
had a death when i was on the on the
jump team
uh i remember i was doing like my
whatever my jumps to get my gold wings
when i first got the team like i didn't
i tried it but
they sent me down to the freaking brown
field to go get some jumps and the
jump team was jumping and they did like
a
down i'd never seen a free fall person
in my life never seen a free fall jump
and i
i landed and got my shoot all packed up
or whatever
and then income the leap frogs and they
did a
down plane they were going a thousand
miles an hour as far as i could tell and
they were so close to the ground and i i
i could hear them say break
yeah and i was like holy shit this is
insane
we had a guy shoot himself he broke too
low and went into this
stadium which at the time was uh
jack murphy that was a long time ago
uh and he uh hit like four seats and rip
them out of the ground
those things are bolted into the ground
into concrete and he walked away from it
yeah i was tommy marquis yeah you know
tommy yeah yeah you can hit that dude
upside the head with a bat
what a beast man he's gone now i know he
was a good dude
um couldn't hurt him yeah i know that's
what i mean he was just a monster
uh and nice nice teddy bear too yeah
uh you got this little section here
while we were falling towards earth so
you guys are doing all kinds of crazy
jumping while we're falling towards the
earth another guy and i had to crawl out
from underneath canopies to clear
airspace so you guys were doing crew
relative work you're all
freaking wrapped up um i can't say
exactly how fast we were falling
as we were as there were fully and
partially inflated parachutes but even
slowly falling out of the sky can be
deadly i was still recovering from the
tear of
my first cutaway when my second happened
a few days later me and another guy got
tangled up and caught in a helicopter
spin
the deployment bag retraction system on
the tops of our parachutes had somehow
gotten tangled together
we were we were twirling around opposite
each other
falling he was looking directly at me
and eye at him and we yelled back and
forth at each other
cut away no you cut away like the
world's most high stake game of rock
paper scissors he won and i cut away
he's a good long time friend of mine
he's a big pussy he should have cut away
he was scared
i don't even know how that happened well
how you guys got all wrapped up
well i mean i know how the rap happened
but the where our parachutes got
connected to each other was ridiculous
so that those are canopy relative work
parachutes so
that usually when you open a parachute
there's a trailing pilot shoot
well on those because you're doing crew
you don't want that stuff trailing
it has a retraction system on a three
ring retraction system it pulls it up to
the top skin of the
of the parachute and that's what got
connected
on both of ours it was a wrap we were
doing like eight-man stack rotations
guy peels off the top and flies all the
way to the bottom
that's how it started and you get into a
rapid like
five six dudes some get shot out god uh
and some get wrapped up and we everybody
broke out of that and we were just stuck
and did it it wasn't on film no because
we you know what back then
there was no such thing as a little
gopro gopro i mean
guys were still taking i think i
remember going from
paul robinson was one of our camera guys
and he had this ginormous
freaking when he opened his pair she
hold his head
his pull his head down because he had
all this weight up there he'd break his
neck
they used to jump it wasn't film so i
think we had a high eight
which is a pretty large camera it's not
go any clown can jump a
gopro
so uh they had blow tubes on the camera
you had
to take a picture oh that was like
a reticle that's how you uh fire the
oh no kidding you'd have to start the
camera before you went out with the
still camera because they would have a
video and a and a still and they had a
blow tube
you'd have to blow into the tube to take
a picture and then you had a reticule
here i
remember seeing guys jump those little
reticles so they knew where to aim yeah
crazy yeah you guys were pushing the
envelope back then with the with the
jump team
um you did three years there and then
you go
uh back to the teams and where'd you go
did you go to you went to the east coast
i went to team eight what year was that
uh 99 jack
and you and that was kosovo
yeah i was gonna say you rolled on there
um nato was allied with the ethnic
albanian forces and we were tasked with
working with nato
to assist them in apprehending suspected
war criminals and keeping an eye out on
the movements of various warring frack
boring factions kosovo
was a real world test we would do
72-hour special reconnaissance missions
in rugged terrain full of natural
man-made threats we did
25 sr missions in six months averaging
about one a week
with one day of prep three days on and a
debrief on the other end it was a kick
in the butt deployment
and conventional forces don't react to
anything inside of 72 hours
yeah i'll tell you that it's better than
sitting around so you'd get yeah
that's that's still i mean at that time
doing real missions was
awesome well we thought that was the
game for sure for sure
you you can't bond steal freaking the
restrictions that they had on the guys
out there it was ridiculous i mean they
they had to put
riggers tape over their magazine well
they had to put rigorous tape over their
magazine
everybody that was out there was
supposed to do that we didn't do it
i mean it's not unusual to have when
they had to do they had an a.d
at the front gate with a 50 cal but
that's their clearing process
at the end they pull the trigger yeah
yeah
why don't you kind of pull the trigger
and clear and save a weapon
well at least you got it i hope you had
a point in a safe direction he did okay
we'll you ever seen a 50 cal shoot 10
feet in front of you
pretty impressive so that's 99 come back
from that point
again i'm skipping a bunch of stuff here
really cool information about what those
deployments were like that's why people
got to buy the book
to get some of those details
jumping ahead a little bit uh reported
to naval special warfare group 2
training detachment on
september 8th 2001.
new instructor role be there for two
years
that was the week 9 11 yeah i was going
to say september 11th so you just check
into trade
nobody wanted to go there of course not
when did you model now when did you uh
what were you teaching i kind of bounced
around i got over there did all the air
stuff
uh at first then i did land warfare
cqc i just kind of bounced around all
over the place
yeah i mean trade has become
such a great place to develop
seals i mean it really has and back in
the day like when when you and i first
got the team
i know no one wanted to be in training
cell and and i did the old guys did the
old warrants
yeah they they did the old master chiefs
that's when masters you couldn't figure
out what a master team did in the seal
teams yeah
i'll tell you i got some good advice
from some of those old master chiefs and
warrant officers that would say like hey
if you want to learn this stuff you got
to go teach it
yeah and i was lucky enough to go into
training sell at seal team one spent a
couple years there and it was
i did i learned i was trying to figure
out the other day i made some estimate
like 50 percent of what i learned in the
in the entire teams
was was working for whatever it was
three years or two two and a half years
and training sell at seal team one
and watching ten groups do the same
thing ten groups what best
teaching teaching the junior officers
that are going through sdt how to do an
iad like
how what to react in these different
situations then watching them and seeing
the mistakes they make
that was 40 of what i learned another
big chunk of what i learned was when i
was a trade at later on
uh you know same thing you're teaching
guys you're watching them do it you're
seeing the mistakes they make you're
putting them through drills you're
seeing
the same platoons go through the same
training evolutions
what the leaders do what mistakes they
make so yeah going into training cell
and training detachment is a great step
and it's a great system now because guys
go
they you know they get they're an e5 and
then they go there they make e6 and then
when they're a platoon lpl they just got
done teaching the stuff man they're
ready
most of the time well yeah they're
getting there a little bit faster than
we used to also
yeah yeah yeah it's a little it's way
more formalized the way it all works now
which is
freaking good for them well i just left
trade it i was a contractor there
well when i left the care coalition
after seven years i went to teach in
military free fall had an injury and
then went to cqc
salk yeah and it was interesting seeing
guys
that when i was the platoon chief are
now like leaders they're
sure man guys at e6 is when i was a
platoon chief are now master chiefs and
some of the new guys are doing their
platoon chiefs lot it was fun to watch
watch them go through and
it's i was terrified too when i was
doing my platoon chief slot
you know like i said we have air
insecurities i didn't want anybody to
get hurt i want to
make sure i i provided everything that
the guys needed
uh they used to tell me when i started
the micromanage hey
chief get out of my back pocket because
you can't manage all that crap
quite honestly the there were guys that
were more experienced
that were junior to me when i was in
charge
and you just got to know when you know
what you know and what you don't and let
the people that
are more experienced you know take those
reins
yeah and you got to be uh you got to
have the confidence in your leadership
that you can go oh you're
hey you've done this sort of thing
before you run it nope no factor no
problem
good to go micromanaging hurts oh yeah
it's freaking it's a disaster a lot of
hours
uh so um so then you get done with trade
you go to team four you're you're
you go you go on deployment where'd you
go
baghdad uh yeah you go you go into
baghdad
i know you got into some team four at
the time was actually they had
nine details which was huge there was
nobody nobody in the seal teams wanted
to do the psd yep
so yeah for people that don't know one
of the
major taskings that the seal teams got
in
2004 i think it started in 2004
was to protect the senior leadership of
the new iraqi government
everyone well well not everyone but a
whole bunch of people wanted to kill
those guys
and uh the people that got the job to
protect them
was the seal teams so that's what
you know you did and then of course
there's a whole lot out of doing that
well there's a whole lot of things that
that are
that are wrapped up in doing that
because if you're proactive about it
that means we're going to try and
capture bad guys or kill bad guys that
might be trying to target our people
we're also doing intelligence gathering
we're going out and figuring out who's
trying to kill these people
um that's a great setup that's what i
did yeah i didn't do the actual
inner ring of protection i was far out
of ring
looking for threats that were going
after
targets within those psds yeah
yeah and we had nine and they all what
every
every one of those politicians i want my
navy seals
you don't want to work with you people
yeah that was a harsh
harsh one harsh pill to swallow for a
lot of guys i got lucky i
i was it started right after i left and
it ended
before i came back well i think it all
got turned over there there's actually
military units that that's what they do
yeah and they got turned over to them
yeah um you did have some good times on
that one here we go we were speeding
down the road and slid to a left turn as
soon as we made the corner i nearly
smashed into a makeshift road block
we must have been moving too fast as we
caught the roadblock construction crew
off guard we still had their
who still had their ak strapped to their
backs
their friends had all taken up positions
on the right side of the road and had
their weapons trained on us ready to
shoot as we sprinted around the corner
in a split second the construction crew
found themselves in a very awkward
position pinned between us
their friends and their friends who
wanted to shoot us in the confusion we
managed to get the jump on them
the lead humvee was equipped with a mini
gun
those things are awesome
i know i have to use a certain level of
reverence when i say that because it is
so awesome to have a mini gun on a homer
um and the gunner had the reflexes of a
mongoose 40 feet away
the targets and their rifle wielding
friends i had a front row seat to the
action when the gunner opened up on all
of them
i had not seen a mini gun in live combat
before so i was a little surprised by
what happened next
by the way there's nothing mini about a
minigun it's a pedestal mounted six
barrel rotary machine gun that shoots as
many as 6 000
rounds of 762 by 51 every minute
and the bullet is about the size of a
triple a battery but let's spit so fast
fast out of the gatling style rotating
barrels that it looked like a red laser
beam and sounded like the mating call of
some bizarre
prehistoric bird the first volley
bullets hit one guy in the chest as he
practically vaporized in a
burst of red mist as this was going on
about 50 yards up the road and
another enemy fighter popped up and
fired an rpg directly at the lead humvee
the one that was firing the minigun i
couldn't see the rpg but i saw the
humvee
10 feet in front of me lift up drop back
down with a crash and catch on fire
the gunner didn't even flinch he just
kept on shooting
in 30 seconds the 25 or so ambushers
including the rpg trigger men
had all been killed and were all red
piles of flesh spread over the street
when it was over we secured the area
salvaged what we could from the still
burning humvee
and then destroyed it with a thermite
grenade the minigun
turned 25 human beings into shredded
flesh in less than a minute
that was quick i thought and then i felt
weird because the next thought i had was
that was awesome awesome because we did
not get killed then because the power of
the minigun
this was the first time i'd seen people
in the process of dying but it was
not the first time seeing dead people my
life and training had prepared me for
these situations my constant inoculation
of violence and stress made what would
have been
grotesque and unbearable to many an
acceptable situation to me my trauma had
conditioned me to accept the
unacceptable
that's what war does it changes the way
you view the world i found no pleasure
whatsoever in killing the enemy
however this was an outcome of war
everyone at some point was someone's
child
but that thought is lost in war the most
profane
aspects of war is that it deletes the
humanity
from humans
you pretty much forget about everything
you believe
you know you're not thinking about that
when when you're in a gunfight you know
theology religion political
whatever politics dude's trying to kill
me
uh i'm gonna go work on him you get home
from that deployment
and then then you did that when you get
rolled into doing a platoon chief
uh yeah
do your workup um how was the workup
uh well
the workup prior was pretty interesting
uh because i
interfaced with all the guys that were
gonna be in the platoon as a platoon
chief and
i remember breaking uh one of the guy's
nods on right before an op
he didn't know i was gonna be a splatoon
chief he kind of chewed me out i was
like dude don't put your stuff on the
ground i won't step on it
um i did feel stupid about that though
but the workup is you know pretty pretty
standard we were on an 18-month cycle i
think
on that one i think it was 18 month
cycle so it's a year-long work up
you know broken up into the three into
three parts you know pro dab everybody
going to schools
and ult just doing all the standard
ckc salk air did you guys know that you
were going to iraq
when you formed up we were kind of the
bastard children too everybody was
looking for the shiny object and at the
time that was
some task force and uh we got what was
uh thought to be the least of the shiny
best deployments which was fallujah and
they the guys that were there weren't
doing anything
but we we worked different we worked
intel different than they did and we
were really busy
i did 140 da's on that deployment which
is
i talked to guys in the sealed teams to
do 100 da's on the deployments
unheard of and then on top of that
teaching medical classes to to the
military units that they're you know
second and fourth iraqi army brigade and
teaching tactics and how to patrol and
trying to work with the met teams
it's you know when you run a target
for your regular job it's kind of hard
to come and be a mit team
and in fallujah proper you know
and run a military unit especially when
they don't speak english
their standard of work is not what
no it is not and that was one of the
hardest things for us to get to
was we when we first got there we we had
these expectations that they were gonna
get to the level that we were
at least close and uh that's just not
gonna happen you gotta see okay
this right here this is what we want
them to be at but right here's gotta be
acceptable
and this is kind of the way it was over
there yeah you gotta definitely adjust
your standards in a real big way yeah
but it's kind of cool because i'm
thinking about you know your last uh
your previous deployment where you were
kind of gathering a lot of intel and
stuff like that and then you roll out
because as you know we drive our own
operations and if you can make
you can find intel and you can put it
together you can put up a target package
let's go hit it you know that's
you know to get that to get a bunch of
da's done like that it's
it's not the sexy thing to do the hard
part
is getting the target packages put
together the fun parts going out and
hitting them yeah most team guys
just show me what door i don't even care
they show me what door
it's a lot harder to get the information
so you're
on this deployment you're doing all
these da's
and now we're going to get into
april 2007
northeast of fallujah when the shooting
stopped
i was still on the floor lying on my
left side
so this is picking up where we started
the this whole
this whole podcast out when the shooting
stopped i was still on the floor
lying on my left side i pushed myself up
to my knees i don't remember hearing any
of the gunfire but now the sounds began
to register in my ears
the two men who had stacked up directly
behind me in my room clearing train were
our iraqi scouts
the second man in our train took a round
to his chest plate
and knocked him clear out of the foyer
ironically that round may have saved his
life
he'd originally been within an arm's
length behind me as we'd entered the
room the third man in my stack
had been shot as he entered the room an
ak-47 round smashed through his
bulletproof
chest plate he'd fallen dead in the
doorway
the chance factor was insane once fired
a bullet can be
unpredictable the internal milling of a
gun's barrel causes bullets to spin in
flight some bullets will begin to tumble
through
the air at low speeds while others are
designed to tumble and cartwheel after
hitting a target
which can cause some brutal damage it's
likely that we were all hit by the same
type of bullets
at nearly the same time shot from the
same gun but the damage to each of us
was significantly different the balance
of my room clearing train
five or six other guys hadn't been able
to get in the room because of all the
volume of fire
i moved from my knees and stood to my
feet
felt like there were 200 pounds on my
back i took off my helmet and used the
white light on my damaged pistol to
survey the room
one of our other iraqi scouts entered
the room he had been behind clarky
and followed him into his room the
bullet that hit clark bypassed all three
of the iraqi scouts stacked up behind
him
these three made it into clarky's room
and had gotten trapped in the back of
the house when the shooting started
the scout had been part of the original
group of 10 recruits who had been with
us since the first day
he spoke decent english and gave me a
report
one seal killed in action one iraqi
scout killed in action
two detainees and six women and children
at this point i actually didn't even
realize that they had left
it it didn't register yet
yeah this is um you know when we started
getting reports about
what had happened during this you know
and and
i just remember thinking this is just
hey this is just pure insanity you know
and um
a lot of guys felt guilty for leaving me
in there but i can
i mean i had to talk to a lot of guys
like hey we didn't do anything wrong
that night
nobody saw me go in there you guys
followed protocol that we would always
follow
uh you didn't blow up the house because
you didn't have a full head count you
did that right
you know so everybody did everything
right and i don't know
nsw sometimes with the knee-jerk
reactions that we would have
to uh try to
make everything as safe as possible
which we're good at but even if you do
something
everything's right bad things can happen
you just can't
you know can't minimize all the threats
to the point where there's no more
threat
you just can't do it and you can also do
really dumb things and make big mistakes
and everything
turns out perfect you know and you can
do everything things can go wrong
perfect plan goes to shit in the first
30 seconds right
um rewind it a little bit this is what
you said
it was surreal like something out of a
movie time slowed down
almost to a stop and everything happened
in super slow motion almost as if i were
watching a scene unfold frame by frame
second scene like minutes a slow-motion
torn of bullets flew at me
i could clearly see all the bullets
coming at me
i had total auditory exclusion there
were no sounds
i'd never been shot before so i had no
idea how it felt in this strange
slow-motion scene
i had a mental conversation with myself
hey am i actually getting shot right now
it occurred to me that those
sledgehammers smashing all over my body
were bullets hitting me one after
another
it was in this moment that i said my
first real prayer
god please get me home to my girls my
wife and two young daughters were
halfway around the world
in that instant i felt them and they
felt
me i felt like a bullet dodging
character in the movie the matrix only i
wasn't dodging any of the bullets
they were hitting me my rifle was shot
out of my hands
bullets whizzing past my head hammered
into the men entering the room behind me
even as i continued to penetrate down
the left wall nobody else in my train
would be able to
make entry as all four of the enemy
continued to fire directly into what is
known as the fatal funnel
the dimly lit doorway in which i was
standing
the enemy bullets triggered my rage and
drove me to act it was
then that my body became became my mind
and took over
i suppose that's what habit is when
somebody when the body overrides the
mind
and acts without specific instructions
from the brain
my right hand instinctively reached down
for my secondary weapon a pistol
my hand was on autopilot as it unhooked
the rubber strap i'd fashion to keep my
pistol secure
and with a fluid push fluid forward push
and pull the very same motion i'd done a
hundred thousand times in training my
weapon released from my holster
i aimed my pistol engaged the enemy
fighter directly opposite me down the
left wall he was glaring at me with his
weapon throwing rounds directly at me
i returned fire four or five rounds for
my weapon and caught him in the face and
chest as he stared at me
his head jilted back i saw the life
leave his eyes like a light going off
i knew he was dead as he melted into a
pile in front of me
i landed next to the dead man on my left
years of training and muscle memory
without any direct orders from my
brain lifted my arm arched it and aimed
my pistol at a young male figure
maybe in his early twenties as he stood
up and moved toward the doorway
i was still on the floor when i watched
him pull a hand grenade from the front
of his vest and pull the pin my right
hand
pointed at him my index finger squeezed
the trigger i saw the bullets exit my
pistol and
spin clockwise as they flew toward him
leaving a green vapor trail in their
wake
i watched my bullets punch into one side
of his head an exhaust of blood and
brain matter instantly exiting out the
other side
i shot him dead as he attempted a
suicide mission to run out in the foyer
with a live grenade where my fellow
seals and iraqi scouts had stacked up
attempting to enter the room my rounds
dropped him in his tracks
as he fell forward i saw the grenade
release from his hand and rolled toward
me
then it detonated
this is crazy one of our newly arrived
seals from team 10. so these are the
guys that just showed up this is
probably this kid's first op
yeah but he was he was the platoon
chiefs oh okay so he was good to go
uh one of the newly arrived first night
though it's still always
their first night one of the newly
arrived seals from team 10 was outside
under the carport looking into the
room's only window when he saw my
bullets enter the enemy's head he
watched as the enemy fell
the ensuing grenade blast shattered the
window spraying shards of glass into my
teammate's face
this was his first mission in iraq new
way to greatness a way to start a new
job
grenade blast knocked me unconscious
when i awoke a few minutes later i was
fully lucid and lying on my left
side looking across the room at two men
both were firing their weapons
over my head out the window directly
above me
the grenade blasted twisted my helmet
rendering my night vision goggles
unusable
the light from their muzzle flashes and
the dim glow of the gas lamp in the
foyer were enough to clearly illuminate
the men standing no more than 10 feet
away from me
i heard no sounds it was totally silent
i was in a very bad place in the middle
of a gunfight
if the enemy caught a glimpse of me
glaring up at them all it would take for
them to finish me off with both of them
to point down
pull their triggers and unload high
velocity bullets into me
if i could clearly see them then they
could see me too for an instant
i thought about playing dead but in that
same millisecond before the thought
could be
fully evaluated my anger rejected it
outright i had never been so angry a
feeling of determined ruthless rage
it seemed to be stored up somewhere deep
inside me and something just snapped
in that moment my rage consumed me my
world closed in and nothing else
mattered to me but destroying the two
men standing still in front of me
i would fight back and kill them before
they killed me
another crazy thing about this is that
there were some holes in me that don't
line up
like i get two holes in my back uh
you think they shot you when you're
unconscious that's the only thing i can
come up with uh
i had two rounds in my back that
shattered my right scapula
and there's no holes in the body armor
so i think i they took the pistol
and shoved it in there and then they
shot me twice in the butt
the only way i could get shot in the
butt is that someone stood over top of
me
i don't know why they didn't put one in
my head she looked at the helmet more
and maybe they tried to shoot me in the
head and the helmet just got in the way
but this this round right here
uh four months after the incident
this is around you're not wearing around
your head it's a nine mil round
that i got shot in a butt with and i
didn't know about it
that it was still in me until i went to
a procedure to get a stint pulled out of
my bladder
four four and a half months later and
they took an x-ray of it and came back
in
x-ray tech was like hey you know there's
a bullet in your head that's how i found
this bullet
but the way the hip is you know that
that arch right there
so it was right there and it
from 2007 to like two years ago was in a
chiropractor and he took some x-rays and
it had moved then he took a side profile
and it was literally at the surface of
my stomach
and then we had i had some medics cut it
out
we thought it was gonna take like five
minutes i'll show you the pictures
got a video of them cutting it out in
the back of the suburban oh there you go
proper dinner break proper surgery
oh going back to this i didn't know it
at the time but i was lying unconscious
on the floor
while i was lying unconscious on the
floor my seal teammates were outside the
door of the room trying to get
a shot at the enemy two of our iraqi
counterparts were the only eyes that saw
me enter the room
in the chaos that ensued they were
unable to communicate my location to
anyone
the volume of fire coming from the room
through the door and out of the window
was so excessive
that there was no way anyone else was
getting into the room the team decided
to pull everyone back and call an
airstrike to neutralize the target
and me with it as the team pulled back
from the house connor my other seal
teammate was shot and wounded
by one of the two remaining enemy
fighters firing over my head and out the
window
while i lay on the floor my teammates
worked their radios calling for the
status of each other and what was going
on in the house i heard nothing
as the remaining elements of my assault
team departed the house and moved to a
safe dropping distance from the target
i was lying on my left side with my
pistol still in my right hand just like
before my arm reached up and aimed at
one of the men
standing in front of me and my finger
pulled the trigger i couldn't hear the
gunfire but i felt my hand
jump rounds exited my weapon and i
watched the projectiles fly in slow
motion as they punched into his body
small holes burst open in the fabric of
his shirt where my bullets entered
his face contorted into a bizarre
combination of surprise and pain more
surprise than pain
in less than five seconds i ran a
magazine dry completed a magazine change
before the two enemy fighters figured
out
i was still alive and i was shooting
back at them my bullets drew their
gunfire away from my departing teammates
their full attention and bullets were
then directed back at me
the enemy fighters were now both so
close to me i remember the stunned look
on their faces as they pointed their
weapons
back at me and fired a round from one of
their ak-47 struck the bottom of my
pistol and dislodged my
guns magazine my pistol jammed and i
felt the gun's grip
crumble in my hand another enemy bullet
sailed clear through the foot of my
magazine
i opened my hand slightly to release the
shards of broken plastic that were once
my pistol grips
the grip seemed to absorb the shock
shattering like an armor plate
i was fortunate to have this type of
weapon any other model would have been
smashed to bits or been shot out of my
hands
my palm was now pressed against the
gun's internal springs
the bullets that struck my pistol caused
my weapon to malfunction i squeezed the
trigger but nothing happened
i quickly cleared the malfunction with
the tap of a
on the bottom of the magazine to firmly
reinsert into the pistol a rack of the
slide then squeeze the trigger
i had done this tap rack bain
malfunction drill so many times that it
happened
automatically all the while i was still
being shot at from
no more than 10 feet away an instant
later well before the human brain could
process
what and how it had happened my hand
aimed the pistol at the other man
standing across from me
my fingers squeezed the trigger i saw
the rounds twisting
as they exited my pistol flying toward
him and entering his body
then around tunneled into his face
i emptied the magazine to both men as
they crumbled on the floor in front of
me
i loaded my last magazine into my
damaged pistol i was lying on my left
side
leaning against the man who i had first
shot when i entered the room
i pushed myself up with one hand and
reached behind with the other
placing my pistol against my dead
enemy's motionless body and fired
several more rounds
seconds later all four enemy fighters
were silent their dead bodies lay in
pools of their own blood
and piles of spent bullet casings a
metallic odor
flooded the room blood and urine leaked
from their bodies onto the floor
i knew i had been shot i felt heavy like
there was a few hundred pounds
sitting on my back it was difficult to
breathe
the fight was not over and the worst
battles
were yet to come
crazy gunfight
my left thumb was almost shot off too i
got i had around go through this
this joint right here when i
i didn't figure it out until later after
i got up and walked around
tried to take my gloves off uh but i put
that pistol in this left hand
and reached over and shot somebody like
this my thumb was
like almost hanging off the only thing
was holding on was my glove
i mean look how lucky i am though yeah
still got it just won't bend
crazy yeah the the the weapon
functioning i mean
you still have the magazine i did go
back
after about five months and i was like
hey i want that pistol you know we
already cleaned it up and
put it back in circulation so somebody
else was using it and i was like
i want that pistol did you ever get it
no
damn no yeah the um i was thinking about
this you know
we started off when i started off i was
talking about how you know you can get
shot one person gets
shot one person can catch a little tiny
piece of frag
like the size of a freaking the size of
a
pebble yeah and kill them yeah you pop
the femoral artery
or you pop an artery up here that's what
happened to clark we he had one around
basically just go right through his neck
right here
it was just hit that artery
it was quick i mean when i found him he
stopped a smile on his face
sitting upright position and he was 27
years old at the time
got a shirt on
that was his second deployment yeah
i needed to secure the building myself
so i moved to the foyer with its glowing
lamp and then to the room directly
beside where my gunfight had happened
there were six women and children all
sitting in the far corner screaming and
crying i pointed my white light at them
and yelled shut up none of them spoke
english
but they all became silent
that's also the room where i found
clarky
he was just inside the doorway sitting
down with
both legs spread out in front of him
resting upright and leaning back
slightly on his rucksack
karki's trademark smirk was frozen on
his face with his lips curled
in a smile he looked so peaceful
he had been killed instantly by a round
that had come out of my room
i tried to move him from the view of the
front door but he was too heavy
clark schwedler was 27 years old
it would take over a decade for the
magnitude of clark's death to penetrate
me
my tears now are often spontaneous
triggered by a fleeting memory
a mixture of accumulated losses or just
a random thought
at that moment though i couldn't stop
and grieve over clarky
i needed to secure the building and
protect my teammates
in another room in the back of the
compound i found two enemy detainees our
iraqi scouts had made entry into this
room discovered the men and cuffed them
i checked their flex cuffs and put one
of our iraqi scouts in place to guard
them i positioned our other iraqi scout
at the front
entry with specific orders to shoot
anyone who tried to come into the house
i knew that i was shot up i walked
around and cleared the house with my
damaged pistol
each time i turned my head i could feel
my radio earpiece snag on my body armor
i plugged my earbud in and keyed the
radio to ask for a status in the house
but no
but my radio had been shot it still had
a tone but no signal
my radio was smashed i needed to contact
the team i tried to swap out my radio
with clarky's
but my gloves were slippery from all the
blood i just started to pull off my left
hand glove when i saw that my thumb was
barely attached to my hand
it flopped into my palm there was a
bullet hole through the glove
i must have been shot in the thumb when
the enemy shot at my pistol destroy
destroying my gun's grips i decided to
leave my gloves on eventually i managed
to switch out my radio for clarkie's
i moved back into the room where my
gunfight had happened i felt safer there
as i knew everyone in it was dead
it was there that i made radio contact
with the rest of the team
hey this is mike i'm still in the house
it's secure we've got four enemy killed
in action
one iraqi scout killed in action
one seal killed in action
two detainees
six women and children
oh man they called the qrf that night
took them hour and 15 minutes to go like
five miles
five miles when did they activate the
qrf when they probably when they started
backing out of the house
uh as soon as we always initiated the
qrf as soon as a
gunfight started as soon as there was a
tick we would initiate
qrf so they would get ready
and then we could launch them but back
then i mean that that area was so
we went after this target one other time
we got id'd on the way in yeah
and those are some of the cool details
that you put in the book
which like i said that's why people have
to buy the book if they want to want to
get the rest of it because the
background behind it you know you
explain the efforts that you guys had
made to
hit this target and it was a terrible
area pretty much one way in one way out
unless you wanted to do like an extra 75
kilometers to get
and that if you didn't get lost back
there
because i mean the maps were inaccurate
and
i mean your greatest threat over there
wasn't getting into a gunfight it was
going to and from that was your biggest
threat we got ied i think sure
six times on that deployment and you
know when that when it happens over and
over again they start looking
who's here every time and i was one of
the guys okay mike's possible
one of the two possible id magnets
because every time we get id'd one of
you two is there
or both of you are there actually we're
both there for all of them so
how big how many seals did you have with
you how many seals were on the top
uh our normal force we could take a
little bit more if we had birds but
uh a normal force and a half of it had
to be iraqis right
and we don't give them mods and radios
so you have to make
corrections for that like we have to
drive the vehicles
so it would be like 22 guys but that
would include a terp
you know a half iraqi force
occasionally brought this marine i had a
dog that
never found anything but a pistol
holster
he did say that dog might have got baked
in the car i mean it gets warm out there
they're like 22 but we go out with six
humvees yeah there's only
four seats and well five yeah you got
the gunner but the way we work
six people in a vehicle you're only
getting uh four people that are actually
going to work
maybe three inside yeah so
i've worked with other units where they
leave everybody gets out of the vehicle
and only the gunner stays i don't like
that
that's the rules say who does that but
we don't like that plan the um man for
you to
like just go back into full-on team
guy mode of okay here's what's going on
i'm shot up
i gotta finish clearing this house by
myself get the house cleared
do an assessment set security and then
contact the team and say hey it's mike
target's secure
damn i was there i don't believe it
freaking legit man i was definitely in
shock
i did miss a room i missed the stairs
upstairs to the
prayer room upstairs so they had to
clear that
i missed it but i deconflicted the front
door they came in they re
re-cleared the house because i had to
pull the guy off the front door that i
told shoot anybody that came through
because they were taking fire from the
outside you know when
when the neighbors know that you're
there some people like to shoot out the
window at you
which was a lesson that we learned early
on because
who doesn't like to blow up a door but
sometimes you don't have to blow it up
sometimes you just turn the doorknob
sometimes that doorknob works
and uh when you blow up the door the
whole neighborhood knows you're there
people take pop shots out of you yeah
freaking awesome man awesome work
um i also got an ak round
that's where i got the idea for this
necklace uh
the guys found when they took my body
armor an ak round fell out of it
and it's slightly flat on one side and
it's got rifling on it
so that's how you know that it actually
came through a rifle barrel
but that one hit me inside of 10 feet
and
it's completely intact i mean it's like
barely flat on one side i
can't explain that one either but i did
get shot in
the right places like i know guys that
got shot in the femur
you hit you hit bone it changes
everything i only had two bones hit my
left thumb
and my right scapula uh
i did have a round go up with the in
inside of my right thigh
which is probably the one the doctors
are the most amazed about because
if you know about the kinetic energy
it's not the energy that's being pushed
in front of the bullets what's being
pulled
and all the cavitation and how it
ruptures organs and ruptured
blood vessels and arteries that should
have popped my femoral artery
because that ran from my knee right
above my knee all the way up to my inner
thigh
and that was definitely an ak round
because
the hole in my leg it looked like
someone took a cookie cutter of an ak
round
and cut it out and the gunshot wounds
healed weird they started off small
and then they got bigger as they healed
and then they shrunk
i didn't have any bad exit wounds
everything went through me i got a bad
accident
out of my right armpit that blew out
but it's kind of actually hard you know
i'm claiming 27 and it's the best of my
knowledge
uh but you know the one that went
through my left thigh might have been
the same one that went through my
scrotum
i don't know but i'm not going to ruin a
good story hey bro when i say we round
up
quite honestly those ones that hit the
body armor
i was more aware of the ones hit the
body armor i had no idea where else i'd
been shot
until i pulled my glove off i knew i'd
been shot in the chest and back
i could feel it i mean i had i had a
bunch of broken
ribs um and i had a confusion on my
right lung
so when i when i called those guys i was
like you guys got to hurry up i can't
breathe i think i got a sucking chest
wound
you know they pulled my body armor off
and there's two holes in my back
and uh they tried to get a reclusive
dressing on it
an old one that we used to use and they
couldn't get it to stick
so luckily it wasn't a sucking chest one
yeah and you got shot with green tip too
right
yeah they took my body armor
after that whatever company does the
investigation and they took it apart
layer by layer
so the other layer body armor spalling
it's that black stuff it kind of looks
i don't even know how to just it's the
stuff that holds everything together so
it's a ceramic plate there's multiple
layers
uh plus i had the carrier on and at the
time we were doing the soft armor heart
armor
the four alpha with the soft i
i can't imagine getting shot in the
chest
with standalone four alpha armor
piercing protection
without that soft armor it's gonna break
every one of your damn ribs
every damn one i only had i think four
broken ribs
i mean you did just so you pop a rib out
every once in a while that sucks
it's freaking horrible man you get that
top of your breath and you can't
uh someone's stabbing me no you don't
want anyone to make you laugh or cough
or anything like that
but yeah the weird thing about green tip
is that if you don't know anything about
it's actually penetrated more through
the body armor than
the ak did oh yeah i totally believe
that so green tip is american
and and five five six five five six
what it's kind of the standard round for
america we got a bunch of other ones
i know but green tip is kind of the
standard
round for let's say an army infantry
unit
and so you might wonder how does mike
end up with green tip in his body
or in his body armor and the answer is
they recovered the weapon and
yeah there was a this all this guy's
equipment to include his name
his lbe his load-bearing equipment with
his magazines in it
still had his name on it they had his
night vision goggles
they had his pistol uh they had a bunch
of
this guy's stuff and it was from what we
figured out
an ambush out in ramadi uh army unit
ramadi
so an army unit ramadi got ambushed they
captured this guy's equipment and then
they put it to use and they put it to
use on you man and the green tip
was the only one that penetrated through
the plate
and made entry into the soft armor it
got about halfway through all the plies
on the soft armor
you mentioned the green tip like um that
it's standard
but what's special about green tip as
opposed to it's
five five six uh it's the standard
ammunition that we use
it's uh we had a lot of problems with it
in
different different places like somalia
um what a terrible place do they origin
women and children is shields but the
the green tip was such a hot round
meaning hot it's it moves so fast that
sometimes it just goes right through
people and it doesn't
doesn't get the a lot of the damage from
the bullet happens
after it passes through and it's the
cavitation and the cavity it creates
behind it it's really not what it does
in front of it
um but the green tip so fast
it doesn't create that cavitation it
just cuts through stuff
but it's also it's armor-piercing right
yeah it's it's fast and it's small
so if it's made it is yeah it punches
through armor a lot as
you know this it's not it's not supposed
to punch through 4a yeah well
who knows when i got hit with the green
tip because i had three rounds in the
chest
and if you look at the body armor it's
already
it degrades with each one they they
they're only going to say yeah
this will save you from one round yeah
that's what they'll tell you after that
we don't know what the hell it's going
to do
because if it i mean if you get if you
take one
in the 10 ring yeah and that damages
everything else maybe that does more
damage
equally all the way around but i i got
hit like here here and here
uh and maybe the green tip wasn't
the first one or maybe it was the first
one before the ak hit it before it was
so degraded that it was
useless i'd hold one of those plates in
front of my face and let you shoot nine
mil into it all day
it doesn't make it net it doesn't even
make a dent you can barely find the dent
from a nine mil yeah and that stuff
yeah i mean pistols are just a lot
weaker than rifles are and then
you have that argument too what round or
shot placement
on shot placement you're all shout
placement huh yeah
and if you're not good at shot placement
then just put a lot there
you know can't tie knots tie a lot
when in doubt overload uh
going back the book 15 minute minutes
after i'd called the team to let them
know i'd been shot the medevac landed
i had to say that because that's
freaking awesome jack asked if i need
any help as we walked together to the
bird about 150 yards and all i felt
heavy and slow as we walked together
over the freshly plowed field i put my
left arm over his shoulder to steady
myself as i moved
jack instinctively reached up and
grabbed my hand which almost ripped off
my dangling
thumb jack let go of my thumb connor my
seal teammate who was wounded in the arm
exiting the house jumped on the bird for
the short flight to the hospital in
baghdad
he was another one of our team's medics
and i thought he that's why he was with
me
i didn't know that he had been shot
until we were in the hospital together
in bethesda maryland that was a new guy
on his first deployment
uh the flight medic was very efficient
crawling all over me to cut off my
clothes and gear to get to my wounds
inserting his knee into every bullet
hole in the process and his defense
there wasn't much
he could touch that didn't have a bullet
hole punched out of it
my seal teammate chris till had been
assigned as my casualty assistance
officer
and would accompany me all the way back
home chris was standing
next to me with a satellite phone you
have to call your wife he said
i refused it first but then i remembered
that my next of kin must be notified
within 24 hours of an incident
brandon was back in virginia beach
shopping with the girls when she
answered
hey i said i don't have a lot of time
i'm coming home
early i got shot but i'm fine i've got
all my limbs
my face is fine and the doctor said i'm
going to make 100
recovery i'll see you soon i handed the
phone back to chris
and the medical team stacked me on the
plane i must have passed out because my
next memory is
waking up in the united states at naval
medical center bethesda
maryland i've talked to a good 50 people
that
talked to me and long stole
don't remember i don't remember them
yeah
i mean one of those people is uh was was
admiral mcraven
yes so that's cool and um
and you guys knew each other you guys
knew each other from team three yeah i
was
my first three commanding officers were
mcty mcnally and mcraven
free three mix uh
yeah you do you do that and and you
you talk about that visit from from the
admiral again
well that was uh from i think i did some
plagiarism
plagiarizing from his book yeah you
pulled so he's got a book out called sea
stories and it's one of the stories in
his book
is you know visiting a guy that just
been shot 27 times
so yeah but yeah you put it in this book
as well he's a good dude i mean
yeah some people might think he's got
some sway political views right now but
uh you know i watched him take care of
people and that's kind of how i judge
people
yeah it's like if you care about people
and you take care of them yeah and
you're not doing shit to
feed your own ego or your own agenda
i mean you got to have your own agenda i
got mine now i mean it's
part of the reason why i sold the book i
want to go surfing all the time
that's all i want to do
yeah it's a pretty interesting story
i guess from your perspective blessed to
have this story and be able to
talk about it you know yeah it's uh
very few people be able to pick this up
and not find something in it that
they're going to be able to relate to in
their own life bro
you got shot 27 times you know and you
did your job i mean it's freaking
that's the least interesting thing yeah
i think um but but just yeah
you put the whole story together and um
yeah man it's powerful and
and like you said there's all kinds of
stuff for everybody and
and you know i'll get into some of it
but a lot of it is is you
trying to explain how you got through
this stuff and you know how you got
through your childhood trauma and what
that trauma turns into and
i mean we'll get into some of it but
that's just a whole nother reasonable
even if you even if you're a
hippie that doesn't want to read a
single thing about war
okay skip those parts because you're
still going to get something out of the
rest of it
well my publisher when we were working
through this were like
mike does this say a navy seal book or a
self-help book i was like leave it
ambiguous i don't care what you call it
i don't care what you call it you know
i'm doing pretty good in the uh
the the ptsd section uh
uh turn on after i'm trailing after you
printing
bumping at your door i have a ptsd
there's a ptsd no you're actually
yours is your books are uh number one in
uh
uh war biographies and oh okay your
books do awesome
i don't i in the ptsd section no not
ptsd
and the ptsd section vander kulk uh body
keeps the score which is one
okay that's the book that you talk about
yeah that's one of the
everybody should read that book
a couple things in there if you
understand your trauma
your childhood trauma then your
behaviors are predictable
you know so if you understand that you
become the person
that you're taught to be invert inside
of the first seven years
and you know what your reaction is going
to be to it then it's predictable and
then you can work on it
like my trigger is i don't like anybody
poke me in the chest
and when i get scared i don't cower
sometimes i might over push back
i don't like to be called names and i
mean i got cursed out by a little 22
year old kid in starbucks a couple weeks
ago
and i had to ask him i was like boy how
old are you
he's like i'm 22 and this kid's flipping
me off because i wouldn't put on a mask
and i was like you wouldn't be talking
to me like this if we were outside
but you know i think that's a problem
with a lot of people in this world right
now you know the keyboard
that the keyboard bullies and they get
behind the wheels of their car and they
act like a bunch of assholes i you know
a lot of people just
don't know that if if you could get
punched in the face for being as rude as
you are you wouldn't do it
yeah we got a society it's just so rude
now
i mean every time you get in your car
it's a damn nascar race people cutting
you off and
i mean i've kind of slowed down i was
that type a driver
in a rush to get everywhere even though
i didn't have a schedule
uh you well sir you talk about like i
said you talk about some of this
trauma and whatnot um
and here's like here's a here's a little
sample of sort of how you start looking
at this stuff
i would spend the next 18 months
training guys shuffling papers and
administrative duty at my new command so
this is this is now your
i think you're back at tray dead again
right yeah i went back to work
inside of five months about four and a
half five months and i was in that
course that we talked about earlier that
communications course yeah uh my
physical good way to call
my physical therapy team became an
important part of my recovery in life my
team was made up of doctors nurses
physical therapist chiropractors and
clinicians who specialized in all type
of care
most importantly this group understood
seal culture
seals tend toward the extreme we think
if one repetition is good then 500 must
be great
i was blinded by my own bias and it
wasn't the first time or the last one
day
long into my recovery i confided to my
nurse that i may have been experiencing
symptoms related to ptsd post-traumatic
stress disorder
i had been sitting in my truck listening
to a radio talk show when the
when the expert being interviewed began
describing the common symptoms of ptsd
the voice spoken a calm matter of fact
tone talking about the autumn
autonomic nervous system and how
sleeplessness constant irrational fears
and hyper vigilance are often normal and
predictable responses to trauma
i listened to a stranger's voice
describe me to me
and i was both relieved and confused
when i told the nurse
who was a friend and someone i trusted
she smiled and chuckled good to hear
mike
we all thought you actually enjoyed what
happened to you in that room
she seemed to understand that being
profoundly
affected by my experience of war was
normal and not being altered
was abnormal this was the first time
that i considered the concept of
emotional
invisible wounds and that i had them i
have come to understand that if the
experience of war does not profoundly
alter you in some way
then you may actually have a problem
when the doctor said that i had been
perfectly wounded
it seemed like a metaphor for my life i
had been beat up just enough not to kill
me
and through the process i earned the
perfect scars of wisdom to survive
my next thrashing i still had no idea
how the events of my childhood
influenced my thoughts and behavior
i'd become very good at
compartmentalization
my self-awareness grew as i uncovered
layers of trauma
i later found that my childhood wounds
had prepared me for a career in the seal
teams
but they also became my most haunting
ones
ironically it took being shot 27 times
to uncover my original wounds
the ones that i never considered or knew
i had
yeah so you know you start looking at
what's going on
and this is this is cool it's got to
read this bro um
because it's a one one page chapter
called the enemy within
i fully accepted all the hazards of my
chosen occupation being wounded was no
big deal to me at no time during or
after
i was shot did i ever think i was going
to die i was provided the best medical
care available
and was sure that my physical wounds
would eventually heal
the real battle began when i returned
home the war in iraq was straightforward
i was expertly trained and had the
unconditional support of a community of
like-minded
highly motivated professionals
professionals as a seal i'd been
institutionalized in a sense
i knew the culture the people the rules
and the objective
after leaving the military and returning
home my life became a confusing
frustrating and stressful mess
i was a prisoner who had been released
from the institution into a strange new
world
there was a destructive a distrustful
cynic
slowly working his way inside me his
voice sounded like my own and each day
he became more convincing
i was surrounded isolated and desperate
this enemy knew all my weaknesses
he was relentless and he eventually
overpowered me
this enemy was me
so a couple things i want to say on on
the btsd
at that point it really wasn't ptsd
at least clinical because i haven't had
any dreams about it
i don't mind talking about it uh it
doesn't bother me
uh it bothered more the people around me
more than it bothered me it was more of
a hindrance
you know that i had to live in a
recliner for three months
it bothered my kids because they'd never
seen me get hurt or sick
it pretty much was my first injury
ever other than broken fingers and toes
i did pinch a femoral nerve
that put me down for about two three
months at one point doing a pt
thing but that was really my only my
first injury because the fingers and
toes don't count
i i don't count
but what had happened to me at this
point
well i want to talk about what i call
false anxiety first
just bad health eating terrible
dehydration drinking too much
your physiology when you're in that kind
and that state of health
feels like anxiety the increased heart
rate
uh the sweaty palms the whole physiology
that goes along with anxiety
because of bad health it's your
physiology reacting to what
people are dumping in their bodies my
particular issue
and what i think healthcare should be is
individual evaluation of each person
to adjust their medical care for for
that because i watch for years people
take medication
for for a migraine and then the migraine
doesn't go away but they get another
symptom so here's another medication for
the symptom
eight medications later uh the guy's
telling me
i still got a migraine i can't remember
what i did 15 minutes ago i'm taking
eight meds for it
um
i had uh in your stomach you have flora
bacteria that breaks up the food so your
intestines can take the
vitamins and nutrients in and i had no
good flora in my stomach so my body
physiologically couldn't even break down
the food so when i got tested
my my urine my stool my blood and they
also used epigenetics
which says your epigenetics your
genetics say that your
body will consume and you utilize
certain types of food
because of your genetics from where
you're from
we see a lot of guys in the seal teams
everybody's on keto why do you know keto
is good for you
you might be hurting yourself or hey the
greeks live for a long time i'll just
eat a greek diet
might not be the one for you because
your genetics don't
i mean it might work but it might not be
the optimum
so i went on to fix mine all i had to do
was take antibiotics for a week and then
i rebuilt it with
diet you know just probiotics and
this is to repair your gut floor after
you did this test
they study everything that's coming out
of you they go oh yeah this is what you
need
so my body couldn't even give me those
nutrients because it wasn't
physiologically working
and i was completely beat efficient d
deficient
uh had all kinds of spikes and uh heavy
metals
was this why you were still in or is
this after you retired and you started
working for the care coalition
it was when i was working for the care
coalition so i've been there for
probably six a little over six years so
you you retired in 2010
yeah and where did you spend your last
so this incident happened in two
thousand would you spend your last three
years
at uh that little creek and you were so
i taught that course
got it and then i was the operations
officer which was the worst job i ever
had
and then but so then you retire out of
there and you get this job at the care
coalition which is
working special operations care
coalition yeah where where
where are you located when you're doing
that job well i'm still living in
virginia beach but almost
the job changed uh when i was initially
hired for that job i had all the nsw
marsack guys and that is wherever they
were
so marsack is on both coasts so i'd go
to
lejeune once once a month i'd fly out to
san diego once a month and meet the guys
out there
nsw and marsack and we were putting guys
in
if we could find a quality of care that
was sufficient we would
put them somewhere you know where they
were from so they can hang out with
their family and
so you're you're when you're in that job
you're an advocate for all these wounded
guys
correct non-medical case manager
non-medical case manager going okay and
this guy's this
kid will tell you hey you know i'm
having problems with my ex-girlfriend
and
i need help with that or i mean just i i
need i want to get back home to my
family or whatever
issues that they're facing is that is
that right was i ran guys through their
uh they were going through a medical
retirement board
i was the advocate for that and i that
was the interface between
them and and the pueblos
the physical evaluation board
liaison officers which weren't really
good
at what they did so i did va disability
i did wellness trips
there was a lot of care that you know
you know paraplegic
doesn't care that it's a test a test
medication or a
test treatment they just want to walk
again
and you know sometimes our medical
system is not going to facilitate that
so
others will so we would facilitate
treatments outside of
network so it was my job
as i described it was to improve
somebody's situation
and i did everything from babysit for
people to uh
you know medical retirement boards i
mean i was a better social worker than i
was a seal
you you talk about some of the cases you
talk about you saw
you know you go through this um you talk
about some of the people that you helped
out
holly was one of my first clients when i
met her she was only able to lie in bed
and scream at the top of her lungs it
was scary
holly was raised in port angeles
washington enlisted in the navy after
high school she joined the military to
create a future for herself and her
family
when i met her she was still the bread
winner for most of her family
she had become an independent duty
corpsman which is the highest enlisted
medical care provider in the navy
she graduated the program and become an
arabic linguist
hospital corpsman chief petty officer
holly crabtree was assigned to work with
the seal team
as they conducted various operations in
iraq
it was april 15 2010 i just joined the
care coalition and holly was nearing the
end of her deployment
she was out doing a medical civilian
affairs operation
when she was shot the bullet pierced her
helmet
fractured her skull and settled behind
her eye she was not expected to live
her crew realized that she was expectant
and coded holly's condition
as hope trauma
she proved everybody wrong hollywood not
give up or stop working
she would have to re-learn how to talk
walk even swallow
i watched her do it all it was both sad
and humbling but most of all it made me
very proud to know her
holly has since made an impressive
recovery and is medically retired
after 13 years of service
i had another guy he's in there sam
same thing shot in the same place
both both um did he have to relearn
everything as well
yeah and they both stroked
paralyzed him on the right side of their
body
he's uh he's working in a program right
now where he goes after uh
child pornographers and traffickers
which is a huge problem in the country
right now
like what 500 000 children go missing
every year in this country
that's insane i mean i'll show you real
slavery that's happening right now
as you're doing this stuff with other
people
this is when you're starting to realize
that you know you should get checked out
yourself
am i getting that right like in the
timeline like this is when you start
going hey man i should get these tests
well the only reason i did these tests
was because
i was having issues and uh people around
me were like you gotta go
go get help go talk to somebody and i i
refuse to
and the reason why i went with this
doctor was because it was the least
invasive and all i had to do was talk to
him on
skype he wasn't even in the same state
and quite honestly i kind of half-assed
it
and it worked uh
i've seen all other people go through
this to include people in my own family
and uh
everybody's issues could be different
mine was bad gut floor i've seen people
that have had
h plyory which is a parasite which is
pretty prominent
which would the symptoms
really look like you're having issues
with a thyroid
so your initial reaction would be well
you're having these issues i'm going to
take you to endocrinologist and then
we're going to make you take these
medications so that
that we fry your thyroid when
the whole time it was just a parasite
that you could just stop eating sugar
and kill it
and fix it that's what healthcare should
be
uh healthcare right now is completely
reactive
they don't treat the source of the
illness or disease
they just treat the symptoms uh
was like 250 000 people die every year
because of medical mistake
we were listening to these people they
almost killed me too
with uh potassium almost had a heart
attack because i had an overdose of
potassium
when another seal who'd been shot in the
eye right next door to me was almost
overdosed
uh ryan jobe was overdosed when he went
in to get surgery just plastic surgery
and then and then they tried to lie
about it
um yeah and those were that was civilian
hospital
it was that wasn't that wasn't the
military that was a civilian hospital
i think medicine's not an exact science
everybody's body's different
and that's why it should be evaluated
individually because
i'm pretty narcotic resistant i wake up
in the middle of surgeries
you got to give me more narcotics to
knock me out if you want to do a surgery
i mean i'm going to wake up and fight
good luck getting somebody to do surgery
after after you make these statements
i'm not gonna get hurt anymore i don't
think so
uh so you're learning a lot about that
you're also doing all like you said
you're doing awesome stuff with
uh with some of the people setting them
up you know you're doing haunting trips
um you end up climbing mount
mount rainier yeah ryan joe climbed that
blind yeah
the year before i did yeah yeah you say
this about that you say our climb had
been in honor of ryan jobe
another navy seal have been wounded in
iraq by a sniper and injury that had
left him totally blind i had met ryan
once at mike monsoor's medal of honor
ceremony at the white house
which i think we were saying today that
was the last time i saw the last time we
saw each other before
right now it's a good party yeah it was
um
good times um
in 2008 ryan jobe climbed to the summit
of mount rainier blind
a year later in 2009 he died as a result
of
hospital error most people know ryan
from the books american sniper and a
warrior's faith
he was the character biggles in the film
american sniper
on my way down i closed my eyes once
and gained a new profound respect for
ryan jobe i couldn't take 10 steps
without opening my eyes
there's some bad parts of that mountain
you're tied to a damn rope too i hated
that when we did that in the seal teams
cold weather training yeah i i actually
never did cold weather training i hate
it
i hate it yeah i mean i was in some cold
spots but i never
you know i got snowed on plenty i froze
plenty of times out in the sleet and
snow but
i never i never did the cold weather uh
the actual cold weather training
the team two guys the old t2 guys used
to love that stuff oh yeah for sure when
i got there
when i got to team two you know i was
hoping that i would get to be able to do
that but
it was already um that program was it
was no longer
like seal team 2 was that it's all
different yeah
you end up going to you end up checking
out some
kind of i guess what is it called
alternative medicine treatment
alternative
options oh yeah
i went full hippie and i went to a place
that was i mean i like those things i
i like the mindfulness practices uh i
should get back to
meditating regularly it does help uh but
i was introduced
at this place to you know shooting with
the recurve
uh you know walking those paths you know
that made with rocks that the indians
used to do
uh so they teach a bunch of mindfulness
practices and they were teaching
transcendental meditation
and i think that's the part you're
getting to where i yeah
it sounds like it was like i mean the
first thing that happens you're doing
this
acid trip or something but yeah no drugs
involved yeah
you're looking at a chair and all of a
sudden the chair turns into human bones
and then you guys are going down to do
some some
some uh therapy with horses and then
i'm gonna go to the book here while the
other participants went to the pen with
the instructor
i stood outside the corral when i turned
and looked at an instructor's face
it was like some type of hollywood
special effects scene i was staring at
him with his damn face
when his damn face morphed into an evil
demon
i froze terrified and trembling it felt
like every cell in my body was vibrating
violently i just stood there closed my
eyes and prayed
god please help me i was sure these
people were going to hurt me when i
opened my eyes
everyone was gone i needed to get out of
there i saw the group standing in front
of the corral
and i said as calmly as i could hey guys
thanks for everything this has been
really good but i need to leave
right now the instructors tried to talk
me out of leaving saying that it wasn't
safe for me to go
and i stood there thinking well it's
definitely not safe for me to stay here
with the demon dude
i tried to hide it but i think one of
the instructors may have known that i
was freaked out one of the female
instructors gave me a ride back to my
cabin i made her use her gps
so i knew she was take where she was
taking me when i arrived back the cabin
i grabbed my bag chucked into my truck
and immediately started driving back to
virginia beach
that was as that was like fully real in
your head
and i did a bunch of research after that
happened to me that's when i started
i had trouble sleeping after that and
started doing research and it's a
an event quite a few people have you
well you
look i thought it was interesting you
immediately went and got a drug test a
full drug test because you thought maybe
you had been drugged i thought i was
drugged
i actually had to stop at a car accident
on the way
that's right yeah you stop in a car
accident and so you kind of knew
that you could you weren't on drugs
because you were doing normal things
uh well i i get into
no no no no wait you see you said you
you knew you weren't insane
yeah because that's why you thought it
was drugs that's what it was because i
was
able to still be objective
that's when you know you're crazy when
you can't be objective
you're like am i crazy if you're if
you're just
completely denying the fact that you
might be crazy
then you know maybe you are you have to
actually investigate it
that's a scary test dude um i don't know
if i passed that all the time
but i mean this if you all the research
i did on it
it happens to a lot of people prominent
people educated people
uh and i say in the book you know i
either saw it happen
because i have some people that were
like hey you just have the ability to
see evil
it was a temporary psychotic break which
hasn't happened since which i've tried
to
like man i don't make that happen again
with meditation because i think it was
the meditation that did it i
popped open different parts of my brain
that i never used um
but i cover my ass in there yeah so
people don't think hey oh my god
the other thing is the kundalini
awakening
yeah i had to go check that out i
watched some youtubes i watched some
youtube videos to figure out what a
kundalini awakening look like and
it's like a yoga like you just we it's
just a weird like spiritual trip i guess
oh yeah and i would say i'm might
confuse people i wear i wear this ring
but
i would say i'm a recovering christian
don't like religion
i'm a spiritual person i know there's a
guy i just he hasn't
she hasn't whatever it is hasn't talked
to me yet so i don't know
i don't know who's right was there like
10 religions on this rock
i do more than that uh
i guess because that bad trip you um
decided you were gonna still keep
getting after it
there was a elliot miller another
awesome seal
um he'd been through some some tbi
like treatments uh he was he was
wheelchair-bound for
a long time he was really overweight
so he went to that pro program at
carrick yeah i did a fundraiser for
yeah yeah so you so you do this you end
up doing this um
you end up trying to figure out how you
can raise money and and the way you
figure out you can raise money is uh
is by doing a triathlon i did a half
ironman
half ironman so i tried to do a full
that's that's when i was training for
that that's when everything came down
yeah so so you end up doing the the the
short one i'll call it short i mean it's
freaking long i guess 13 miles in one it
is short
it's short for a triathlete doing two in
a row was
exponentially so much harder that i
induced diabetes because i didn't know
enough about nutrition
did you induce diabetes before the first
one or while you were training for the
second one for the full ironman
so you do the you do the first one and
everyone's all happy you raise 135 000
uh folks at iron man contact you and say
hey you're
great you got us a bunch of publicity
and it's awesome
chris pratt did it with me too chris
pratt did it with you i'm sure they
wanted to get some of that i didn't know
who he was
like guardians of the galaxy oh that one
stupid movie with a rack talking racquet
they're good movies now i like them i'm
a i'm a fan of chris though
yeah no he seems like a great guy i've
met him um
but then this happened so so they tell
you hey you can do another you know
we'll sponsor you or whatever you can do
it
and so you start now training for this
and here you go i was totally exhausted
and burned out before the half ironman
now i was training for double the
distance
after the race the first race the word
spread about what i was doing and new
donors came to my crowd
rise page to support me doing the full
ironman but i was at a point where i
just could not do my job anymore i was
totally burned out
and the ironman fundraising and training
did nothing but add to my stress
everything started to escalate my mind i
could feel something
was on the verge of breaking the stress
of work training and financial
obligations were all becoming too much i
couldn't sleep becoming edgy and
difficult to get along with
on the best of days 45 days before the
kona race i emailed the iron man folks
to thank them for the opportunity and
backed out of the race
i contacted every donor and offered them
to return all their money i was a mess
at work i couldn't i would get urgent
calls from shrinks
who would say stuff like come get your
guy some of my clients would scare the
medical cl
staff and the doctors knew if they
called the police all hell would break
loose so they called me instead
i would have to go defuse the situation
these evolutions were exhausting and
looking back they were all
well beyond my area of expertise i would
do the minimum
reporting at work then try to sleep or
play video games and attempt to distract
myself from the constant fear of
something bad happening
i was trapped without an escape route
stress accumulates and it was all piling
up inside of me i had no financial help
and i'm not one to ask for any i was
sure that i was going to get fired from
my job this was only the second real job
i'd ever had in my life other
than being in the navy i felt
embarrassed and ashamed and emasculated
i would not leave my home for days on
end i avoided talking to people even
turned off my phone
brenda was troubled she knows me so well
she was gentle at first asking me if
i wanted to talk to someone as i became
more isolated and combative she reached
out to my friends and co-workers
they joined with her and together they
all hounded me to get help
in a year i'd gone from training to do
an ironman triathlon
to not being able to get off my couch i
was in a dark
dangerous place my life had become
unbearable there was guilt
but i think the real culprit was shame
guilt and shame are very different
and controlled my thoughts and behaviors
in distinct ways guilt was about what i
had done or in my case what i hadn't
done
shame was about who i was or at least
who at least who i thought i was
i felt like a a prisoner being
brainwashed every day
my mind seemed to be stuck on a
one-track narrative that became darker
with each episode
every minute of every day there was this
weird repeating internal mylog
monologue that opened with guilt which
created a feeling of shame
i would fixate on things that supported
this monologue
like bailing out of the iron man which i
was which i was sure disappointed the
donors
the treatment facility my clients and my
family my anemic efforts at work
reinforced my shame that's when all the
what-ifs began
chiming in what if i get fired from my
job will we lose the new house and all
my money
what if the people who donated to my
fundraiser think i'm a fraud because i
didn't do the full ironman
these thoughts would lead to
embarrassment which deep into my
feelings of shame
i was trapped in this desperate
repeating irrational monologue
that sounded all rational to me
i personally knew people like dan mark
holly and tyler who had far
worse injuries than me and far more
stressful lives and who were all
managing themselves well but for some
reason i just couldn't put things in
perspective
i was locked in in an irrational
disproportionate
escalating mental prison i sat in my
truck
i had researched how to do it exactly
where to place the barrel and how to
angle the gun
i had practiced it with a cleared weapon
and pulled the trigger i didn't want to
leave a mess for someone else to clean
up
i would not do it in my truck so someone
else could use it the bullet would go
through my heart there would be an
instant of pain and then i would be gone
i would do to myself with one bullet
what four enemy fighters
failed to accomplish with 27.
i stared at the black gun in my hand i'd
used one like this to kill before
i was numb and sad confused and tired i
had cried alone so many times
my downward spiral had come to its final
resting place
at the bottom was hopelessness
the built built-up stress the lingering
effects of trauma my psychological
deficits all
colluded to create a condition of
hopelessness
my mind worked trying to come up with an
explanation to justify my final act
to my two beautiful daughters years ago
in that room at that compound the
thought of not being able to see their
faces again terrified me
images flashed in my mind holding my
daughter's little hand and her own as we
sat together
the way the girls would wrap their arms
around my neck and hug me their soft
little voices called out
oh dad
their smiling faces repeatedly flashed
in my mind
there was the disproportionate feeling
of guilt and shame that relentlessly
stalked me
i felt trapped in a life layered with
overwhelming stress
endless responsibilities meaningless
tasks and toxic people
of whom i felt i was the most toxic
it was all my fault i felt i was
my own worst enemy this time there was a
bullet in the chamber
i was beyond contemplation my mind was
made up
i mentally paced back and forth working
up the courage the same way i had
when i hit my father with the bat
i was getting out of my truck when my
phone rang i looked down at the number
it was scott heintz my boss
i picked up the phone in one hand and
held a gun in the other
i let it ring not wanting to answer
i couldn't do it with scott calling so i
put down the gun
i answered hey scott what's up
and scott says mike i want you to take
the next three months to chill out
i'm gonna pay you relax take your time
and find a new job i'll help you out
however i can
you're beyond burned out you did amazing
work
but there's a time limit for how long
you can do this job
and you maxed it out
my boss and good friend had just given
me the hope i needed to climb out of the
very deep hole i'd found myself in
in that instant i could not have
answered my phone for anyone other than
scott
scott had seen it all before he knew
that i was surrounded by wounded
sick and injured people all day scott
also knew that many of the people who i
had been meeting with
every day for years including patients
their family members
veterans service members and hospital
staff were struggling with depression
it's like an alcoholic tending a bar you
can only hold out for so long
if you're around depressed people all
the time
you become depressed too
i suspect that some of you reading this
may now think that i'm crazy and write
me off
thank you comp for coming this far with
me for the rest of you who have ever
been depressed or suicidal i can tell
you
that while i fully believed at the time
that i was thinking rashly
i know now that i was not
my irrational thoughts had started
repeating themselves the world will be
better off without me i don't care
anymore i just want out of here i'm a
horrible person
my future will just be filled with more
of the same stress these thoughts seem
totally rational and true in my
compromised state
but i had no idea that my thinking was
compromised
what scared me the most about these
thoughts and the entire experience is
what happened to me just a few months
later brenda in her desperation to help
convinced me to
visit a physician who had a protocol to
treat depression and other conditions
i resisted at first of course but
finally agreed to work with a guy
if only to get brenda and everyone else
off my back
that's why i did it
man
you uh get tr it's it's interesting you
know you talk about the um
like now you can look back and see that
you weren't rational
oh yeah but at the time there's just you
know
it's a chemical imbalance i mean it
it's be more people are coming aware of
it now that
the gut brain access uh
i mean
the gut is probably a smarter brain
than the one in our skull
it can't operate properly unless unless
you put
proper nutrients and
vitamins and this doctor is also really
big into the emf
electromagnetic fields you know you know
how we're affected i mean we had radio
antennas over in iraq and afghanistan
you could put popcorn kernels in it
would pop
popcorn what do you think that does to
you
what do you think that does to your
skull and your organs and your cells
we already used resonance as a weapon
you can use microwaves to make people
sick uh well yeah i was a radio man
unfortunately i loved the job but i mean
sat
all those antennas man i was
constantly here as a young guy getting
we took the
what was that thing called the batwing
yeah the vehicle antenna for the
satellite
and we figured well our one of our new
guys put it on
on the radio with a switch so this
oh i see he's running around he looked
like inspector gadget you know with a
helicopter
he had that batwing hanging out over top
of his head
i don't i don't think sat transmissions
are very healthy
but frequencies you know resonance i
mean we could use it as a weapon it
could be used for
to heal
microwaves they've been used a lot to
make people sick
so so you go through all that you kind
of get um this doctor dr
beck sort of puts you on a path
like a new mission of you're gonna clean
up your diet you're gonna stay away from
these
um situations the bluetooth limit your
limit your exposure
to wi-fi and all this stuff which is
hard oh yeah for sure bmf is hard
so i pretty much blew that off
so what did you mostly would you mostly
fix your diet mostly it was diet
uh i got my gut back right
so that it because the way that works
your gut prepares the food for the
intestines for the intestines to do what
they do and if the stomach doesn't work
then
it just it's going to pass through and
the intestines are not going to be able
to pull the nutrients and vitamins and
i mean i don't take any medication now i
uh i am taking mitch's
smashing greens i started off with uh
this doctor put me on
stuff called green juice from organifi
uh so it's it's got all the you can have
in one shake
all the nutrients you know with one
scoop of
protein and one scoop of greens that's
all you need
uh pretty i mean we could live on algae
and you look at all these school lunches
that
these kids were getting not now because
of covid but
i mean they were feeding them crap
they're actually making them sick
they're not helping them
yeah i mean i mean like doritos with
like crappy hamburger meat on it
yeah if it's even hamburger meat yeah
if it's hamburger meat it's not high
grade i can tell you that
so so you get done you go on this
protocol and you say this it took about
two months and even then
i um i would shop for all the foods
meticulously prepare
the meat measure all the meals keep the
detailed food log
i'm sure the process was gradual but one
day i woke up and felt like the black
cloud that i had been hovering that had
been hovering over me with for
years was gone i was able to function to
move and think
think clearly the fog had lifted and the
constant negative internal monologue
inside my head
stopped i felt strong clear and
confident enough to get up
and start moving forward
grabbed my phone opened up my contact
list and started sending text
text messages and making calls i needed
a new job
and that's when you ended up going to
trade uh
back to traded as a contractor i went
back to teaching military free fall or
prior injury i had three events where i
couldn't open my main parachute because
my right scapula
would seize up my whole back and my hand
wouldn't work so i had three high
high speed malfunctions went to reserve
and the last one
ripped my pec off my connects between
your arm
did you get surgery yeah they
reconnected it
but it was a slap tear the whole pack
came out
right here dang so then i went to cqc in
salk
yeah which is which was awesome because
the ttps changed because of me
yeah that's that's a perfect place for
you to go and teach i mean what
better person to be teaching about how
to handle close quarters combat that
someone
don't do what i did i mean we still
teach that uh but there's there's
better ways to do things and uh
different tactics you can use in
different situations you can't just do
the same thing every time
but and then how long did you stay there
for
uh
because you're you're you're retired now
from that job as well right yeah so
what is it 2020 quit 2018
i was i was probably at trade up between
those two jobs for
about three years okay yeah awesome yeah
this one just left that like
last october i think it's it's a cool
thing that the teams do
bringing older guys back that have
experience that some of the younger guys
might not have especially someone with
experience like you and
bring them in there to teach and pass on
those words man that's freaking awesome
that
that we do that in the teams well i
learned a lot there being an instructor
like you were talking about earlier you
know watching 20 different groups come
through
people do different things different
ways and like man that was really stupid
or
man i wish i would have thought of that
uh you ended up getting some tattoos and
uh this was cool you know
mike martin um who's a master chief
team guy that was in vietnam who had
gotten out of the got now gotten out for
like
a long time well he was a training cell
at team three when i got there yeah
he had gotten out for a long time then
he'd gone joined rejoined the navy
and went back through but i don't think
they made him do
like real buds yeah he's like one of
a few people that went through like a
gentleman's course of buds
you know well we had to retread in my
class that didn't make it
was he a reach at vietnam vet uh
i believe so really he was terrible dang
that's kind of like martin's uh well he
passed away last year on that motorcycle
ride
and i'll tell you what he was only 62.
bro we were i was going he was gonna
come on the podcast
and and like i was lining it up with you
know one of our mutual friends and
and we're just you know just trying to
find the date and boom
yeah i was freaking so bummed out that
was the first navy seal book
i haven't read many but navy seals don't
read navy seal books
even though there's so many of them so
many jokes i was just hanging out with
black rifle and i was like hey you guys
want to sell books in here you know all
the military books
i was like yeah it's a good idea but
we'll have to reinforce the shelf for
all the navy seal books
like you're an asshole dude well i was
sitting down with uh the black rifle
guys up in
montana and um it was me and
dudley the archery guy and and then uh
and then jack carr was what's his name
the other owner small
or uh it was evan it was evan that was
who was there it was just so often
what's up because the other guy
got hurt i thought he got hurt matt got
hurt yeah so he couldn't come
but anyways we sit down and and um you
know
evan makes a joke about seals writing
books
and he did it to me too and then of
course i looked at him and i was like
because
i mean it's a funny joke yes but then
when you're actually sitting with two
seals that have written books i was like
oh this is really embarrassing i go
real funny evan they're a great group of
guys they're definitely doing their job
paying it forward for sure man
for sure i mean i i was really bummed
out when i saw well first of all when i
found out that you went to the total
archery challenge there
and i just did i don't know why i didn't
put two and two together well i didn't
find out until after you left montana
yeah so i was like but then the other
thing i didn't know is i
i knew i knew that they were doing
something with uh with the wounded
warriors
but i didn't know what they were doing i
didn't really grasp it again i just
didn't pay enough attention but i could
i
should have gone down there for that it
looked freaking awesome that rolled into
a
huge archery event afterwards so we
there was 25 of us i was one of two guys
that wasn't an amputee
there was a dude there that didn't have
a right arm yeah i saw videos of him you
fight that thing yeah yeah that's all
that too freaking awesome too
yeah dude and she had like 108 yards
yeah there's something real cool about
archery that
uh that it has a lot of similarities you
know to the old job
you know i like shooting the bow better
yeah i do too i i like sharing new bow
better
the main reason is cause it's quiet it's
like there's no like little shock
it's just nice and quiet you can do it
in your yard and it's harder actually
yeah it is harder well it's definitely
harder at range i mean
and then you can pick up a recurve i
haven't done the recurve thing yet
that's cool
is that what you're like primarily
shooting as a recurve these were
compounds but i've got a couple recurves
and it's all instinctive yeah yeah you
just aim and well you can't aim
there's no sights there's no rephrase
that you kentucky windage and go it is
totally kentucky with it
oh yeah there's a couple guys that were
trying to do some long shots up in
montana with the recurves man
yeah it looks fun looks fun i don't know
if i gotta i got a lot of work to do on
the compound before i decide i'm gonna
make it even harder you just turn up the
juice on that thing
man uh yeah one arm guy's hitting stuff
at 108 yards how hard can it be
that's freaking off he's only got one
arm freaking awesome man
just freaking out lopez um
getting close here but you know you say
this it may seem strange
but being shot 27 times then having a
hand grenade
flow up next to me was one of the best
things that ever happened to me it was
the start of a personal revolution
that continues today and hopefully will
go on until i take my last breath
i say revolution rather than evolution
as a result of my experience
i have tossed out and or abandoned every
bias relationship belief and dogma that
has blocked my self-awareness
and joy
you said again i'm reading this stuff
because i know that there's
people i mean people talk to me all the
time about what they're going through
and you know what you say here i think
is really important
i burned through a number of therapists
some were good most didn't have what i
needed to help me
understand how the traumas of my
childhood shaped me as a person and how
those same traumas
make some of my behaviors predictable at
times i had to be pushed into seeing
therapists and doctors by people who
loved and cared about me
i don't know if i can ever thank these
people enough for not giving up on me
when i was so rude and resistant toward
them
i say all of this so you know that at
least for me
there has been no magic pill quick fix
or one size
fits all solution to finding peace and
joy in my life
these things have come to me slowly over
the past decade
as i grew in self-awareness and courage
i suspect your personal peace if that's
what you're searching for
may be gained much the same way
yeah you know i think um that that uh
just letting people know like somebody
thinks oh i'm gonna go see a therapist
and it doesn't work out because that
therapist doesn't have what that per
particular person needs and then they go
see i can't be helped instead of saying
oh you know what i gotta try some
different people
both societal too um
people think that they you know it could
take you
years to get into a terrible mindset
based training telling yourself doing
all the things that make you
believe the things that that you're
telling yourself
and then uh you hit rock bottom or what
you think's rock bottom and you're like
i gotta go get this fixed i'm gonna go
to this one week program
you know it took me two years to turn
into this
disaster area and i'm gonna i think i'm
gonna go to a one week program that's
gonna fix it
and a lot of these programs that i
watched when i was at the care coalition
it does help but there's no follow-up
so there's an improvement while they're
there because everybody's
you know feeding them good food teaching
them the things that
that they can use to you know relieve
stress
uh and they do that while they're there
and then they go home and then just fall
back into the same routine
training themselves to get further into
that hole i mean
that's what medicine is right now you
know people get sick
they think that they can take a a
medication that's going to make
make the sickness go away you know
you're not even addressing why you're
sick you're just
hiding the symptoms they hide in the
symptoms um
i mean like earlier i said i actually
induced diabetes
and it was because i didn't know enough
about nutrition and the only thing i
knew about nutrition is if i was hungry
or not
and my favorite restaurants were the
ones that gave me the most food
i didn't care what it was um
i mean eat an extra large pizza of
myself gallon ice cream and 12 pack of
beer you know that's
that's the winning path maybe not
definitely not
it's funny too because we all know uh
even since we were little kids you are
what you eat but we know it but we don't
practice it
and then you got the fda with that
stupid food pyramid you know you've got
people now
oh my stuff's fda approved i'm like so
what
corrupt organization go eat five loaves
of bread like they told you to no wonder
everybody's fat yeah can you say
pre-diabetic
oh and then they take medication i mean
type 2 diabetes
all you got to do is change your diet it
goes away i did it
i induced it with clif bars
gatorade i wasn't eating twinkies yeah
yeah yeah i was just
you're thinking what seemed like it's
cool yeah when i was also
being trained by an ultra thonner uh and
they're dumber than we are who goes and
runs
yeah she kicked my ass man
and i just didn't know enough about
nutrition and i was just dumping carbs
and sugars into me and
every time i stood up i was almost
passing out that's diabetes crazy as
soon as i fixed it
it went away
here's another little section that i
think people should hear i have a way
i have way more stress and uncertainty
in my in my life today than i ever did
in the seal teams or when i was suicidal
the difference is that i now have a new
resiliency portfolio of people
tools and skills that allows me to
effectively manage stress
almost effortlessly while i do have bad
days and very bad days
they don't control me or impact my
outlook on life
i'm also keenly aware that most of my
troubles
are self-inflicted if you are honest
with yourself you may find
the same is true in your own life
adversity is either a privilege or a
tragedy
depending on how you respond to it
choosing to be a victim of the events
and circumstances in my life
would have been the real tragedy what if
we all viewed view diverse
adversity as an opportunity for personal
growth
to define our life's purpose and to help
others
the reality is that we can but we can't
do any of these things as victims
if i am to evolve which is my life's
mission i can't be a victim
even if my problems are the result of
someone else's actions
i found it easier to find myself than to
rely
on the perpetrator to repair the damage
well that's what a lot of victims do
you're a victim because you're blaming
somebody else
and you're expecting them to fix it and
they're just nobody's coming you know
they're not gonna fix it
yeah so you might as well just take the
blame take take take the ownership and
solve the problem
after everything that i've come through
i'm grateful i think that the gratitude
and service are
i think that gratitude and service are
unseparable
the more i serve the more grateful i
feel that i can still serve and care for
my family my warrior brothers and
sisters and continue to be of service to
all of you
these days i spend my free time hunting
for a perfect surf
and spending time with great friends i
set up a non-profit to help shorten the
distance to recovery from trauma and
depression
we join with people who truly want to
help themselves
we offer these adventurous souls a
community of the right relationships and
a portfolio
of resiliency skills and tools
and what's the name of that it's a
little bit of forward thinking i'm just
on the earl right now so i'm putting in
the paperwork uh it's called warrior
tribe
and uh the focus is gonna be a little
trauma metal on this and
i want to get into uh at-risk youth
yeah you know freaking awesome man the
kids that were like me that are one
decision away from
winding up in the in the federal prison
system or
yeah or winding up on a great career in
the military or some other
path you know it only takes one decision
i got lucky you know
you know what i just want to close it
out with
what you closed this book out with
joseph clark schwedler
it comes in waves now and again there's
an overwhelming feeling of disbelief
that gives way to frustration
then my eyes usually well up
it's been going on for years now i've
lost so many people
it takes a toll
clark was the kind of man you want your
son to grow up to be
he was smart driven had a great sense of
humor
was tough but thoughtful and responsible
he was a born leader and he made us all
better people after missions we'd be
tired but clarky would be working out so
we'd work out too
he was like a swiss army knife he was
our navigator our intel
our intel collections guy a team leader
sensitive site
exploitation officer and one of our
iraqi army
combat advisors he picked up everything
fast and became great at whatever he did
clark's dream was to be a navy seal
he was a midwestern kid from crystal
falls a northern michigan town
of 1469 people
he was a senior class president played
high school football and basketball and
ran track
he did two years at michigan state and
joined the rowing team
knowing clarky he did it because the
workouts were grueling
and he wanted to stay in shape
he followed his heart abandoned college
and enlisted in the navy to fulfill his
dream of becoming a seal
clarky got to live his dream and did
what he loved to do
every time i saw him he had a smile on
his face
what gives me peace is knowing that if i
died doing my job as a seal
i would have no regrets and i know
clarky felt the same way
for those of us who have lost friends
and family members in this war
the losses connect us
while we may be strangers we know each
other well
there is a surprising comfort in being
together in this painful club
we don't have words to describe the
depth of our grief
but we don't need them because we can
feel each other's sorrow
there's a saying time heals all wounds
it doesn't
it only makes them slightly less painful
i may again meet up with clarky on the
other side of this life
and i'm looking forward to it
i know a lot don't we a lot
they just put some new stars and paws on
the
naked warrior in virginia beach i didn't
even know about the dogs that passed
i think one of them was a suicide
died by suicide
a terrible place to be but since i've
been there i know i can't get there
again
that was one phone call from one person
that stopped me so i almost didn't
answer that phone
yeah and i think obviously the lesson
there is uh
what messes a lot of people up the
secondary
tertiary effects
i told our nutritionist about it who
helped me out with the guys that i was
assigned to
told her what i had almost done and she
was like do you know how many people
that would have hurt
i never considered that i thought i was
doing
people a favor that's how rational i was
but i've been around families where
there's been a death by suicide
and it it's terrible what it does to the
people that are left behind
it's a
they don't recover from it
well you know i you know this this
kind of tribute that you wrote there in
the end to clarke
is awesome but you know from my
perspective there's
there's no more powerful tribute than
you can make than
than doing what you're doing right now
you know trying to help other people out
trying to live a good life take care of
family
and and really
sharing all the things that you've been
through and
how you made it through them with other
people
and and i think there's nothing uh
better that you could do to truly honor
clark's
his sacrifice and i do want to make it
clear too
that i am still seeking a continuum of
care
i'm recently looking at a program called
uh save a warrior
which a handful of guys have gone to
the last three years of my life probably
be a lot better book
this is the stuff that i've been dealing
with this last three years and the fact
that i'm able to manage it
is uh is pretty incredible to me uh but
i don't know i think some people think
oh i've had my ass handed me up into
this point
nothing else is going to happen i mean
shit's still going to happen and i've
just
been able to get to the point where no
matter how bad i got my ass handed to me
i
somehow fixed it or somebody helped me
fixed it and i just had that mindset now
i don't care if the rest of you turn
into zombies i'll figure it out when
when it happens but your point your
point in saying that you're still
you still are on the path of
you still know you need help now i think
everybody does
there was a point in my life where i
would have said nah i'm fine but there's
always room for improvement
that's an easy way for for someone to
say you don't have to say you need help
hey there's room for improvement yeah
that's that's a that's a better team guy
way of saying it
because a team guy never wants to say i
need some help but if you say to a team
guy don't you want to get don't don't
you want to improve
99 of team guys say hell yeah i want to
improve
and another thing with that too it takes
you a while to get to a bad state
you know that one week program is not
going to do it a continuum of care
and that's working out good diet you
know
taking care of the things that that
lower the stress hormones
it's it's not just one thing it's it's a
lifestyle change
you can't expect to be well if you're
taking down a fifth every day
and i'm not gonna be a hypocrite i
probably drink too much beer
but but i also take in all the nutrients
and vitamins that i need to before i
drink too much beer
uh well hey man look we've been going at
it
over three hours right now um
where where can people people can find
you instagram
uh yeah my instagram handle is
mikeday5326
my social media is a train wreck until i
hire somebody i don't know what i'm
doing
and my website i have a website my
daughter who used my gi bill to get a
graphic design degree uh did my website
uh it's perfectly wounded.com
okay so that's where people can find you
um
any other any other closing thoughts uh
no i just there is no easy button
nobody's coming uh nobody's gonna take
care of you
better than you can take care of
yourself
uh it's they're i can't
say enough there's not an easy button
you trained yourself to get yourself to
a certain point
that's your mindset that's training and
if you just look at it like that
if you can train into a bad mindset you
can train out
and if you are hanging out with a bunch
of depressed people or people
that are like-minded that that are
negative you're gonna catch it
i mean we used to kill that stuff in the
seal teams there's always one that one
guy
that bitched and complained about
everything and if you didn't
stop it then his buddy started bitching
and complaining
and then it was like a damn disease
the negative thoughts and negative
actions
are not going to fix and
a fit that jack daniels every day
doesn't fix it
you can eventually have to still deal
with it
all right all man those are those are
freaking good good guidance right there
and uh man thanks for sitting down here
thanks for talking with us thanks for
coming all the way out here
um thanks thanks for everything you did
for the teams and for the navy and for
america and
man the example you set for
you know for people not not just for
what you did in the teams but like the
example you're setting right now
being putting yourself out there
explaining how to overcome things
it's freaking awesome man i appreciate
it i don't like giving advice
i'll try to live by example you know we
just came back from black rifle
those people you know
amputees still going through surgeries
and
their lives are so much harder just to
get up out of bed you know a paraplegic
what a pain in the butt that is but they
they still fight through it and
they're living by example and when i was
at the care coalition it did
kind of help me for a long time how can
i complain when
you know dan connauson's above double
above the knee amputee yeah
taylor morse is a quad amp and i've
never seen the guy be upset
so it is it is inspiring to see people
that we
assume have a worse deal which is a hard
thing for people to get across
to like i don't have the right to feel
this way because that guy's worse or
that girl's worse
which is not true you know everybody's
issues or their issues and
they have to be addressed even though
you don't have
the worst deal you know be happy you
don't have the worst deal
now you don't have to fix that one yeah
you might not have the worst deal but
it's your deal and you got to deal with
it
awesome man appreciate it brother thanks
guys
and with that mike day has
left the building awesome to see him and
uh that ends up being yet another
excuse removal podcast
what does that mean meaning
it's kind of hard to make excuses when
you get done talking about mike day
who's been
through a lot and he's not making
excuses
so well echo charles yeah
yeah that's uh it's almost like you can
kind of just refer to that every single
time
you know something's going wrong for you
and probably others too you'd be like
well at least i didn't get shot 27 times
you know it's a true statement
my thumb almost ripped off yeah it's
weird you can keep
or that he can keep his head straight
when he looks down and be like oh yeah
my thumb's
almost off as well you know yeah i i
said this
i said team guy mode yeah and i don't
use that term lightly
but just from reading it and talking to
him about it
using full team guy mode which is when
you're just like all right i'm going to
make things happen right now
just yeah so yeah 20 did
well speaking of
excuse removal what do you think we can
do
to help ourselves and
each other remove some excuses and stay
on the path
stay capable i think stay capable
of course you're not gonna well we all
have our challenges
right like how you guys were saying uh
like people's challenges are more or
less or whatever but
they're ours we have our that's what
you're saying right yeah yeah yeah
yeah but they're my challenges or our
challenges anyway so we're all gonna
have our challenges
but we want to stay capable yeah i think
so for sure with capability
comes exercise i think
well you heard you heard mike mention
about a thousand times working out
right staying in shape eating good food
eating good food supplementation
supplementation is a thing very helpful
thing anyway so yeah supplementation
jocko has
fuel by way of supplementation jackal
fuel
so what kind of supplementation for your
joints is a big one
keep your joints in the game my kids saw
a guy do a backflip it was a big muscle
guy
and he was doing a bunch of other stuff
and there was a kid involved in the
video
and um he was doing so and my daughter
you know she's curious
she's seven so everything that i did she
was like hey dad can you do that
and the answer was yes every single time
and she would be like hey prove it so
i'd have to like prove it you know
and there was like a rope in it too so i
didn't have to prove that part of it
and he she was like he was doing like a
bunch of stuff and i was like
it was the list was going on and on and
i was like i was doing good at first but
after a while i started to get nervous
like bro this guy's pretty started
getting outside of
your realm of capability it looked like
he was about to you know because he just
kept doing stuff
and i looked at him i was like he was in
good shape one of those athletic shapes
too
muscle guy i'm like okay all right all
right and then finally the last thing he
did was this back flip sort of the
finale of the video like saying thanks
for watching and he does a backflip
and i remember back in the day i could
do a backflip straight up
what do you call it a tuck i think it's
called you know the kind of backside
yeah so but i'm like oh man
if i were to bust out a backflip right
now because of course she wants to see
her right now
i'd probably hurt myself but if i warmed
up a little bit
i think i could do it right now i'm
surprised you didn't go for it at the
pool's edge and say
hey listen p i can do it but
i'm gonna do it over here by the pool
just because
i'm cold right now see this guy warms up
a lot yeah that's all right that's
actually what i said i was like yeah
he's warming of course you know she's
like okay so now every once in a while
she'll be like hey just warm up
do it before your workout and i'm like i
gotta bust out the excuse
it's been about 10 years since i did it
and you can get hurt if you don't do it
correctly so the last thing i need is
for me to double down
and get injured in front of my daughter
you know kind of blow her whole image of
me but she knows i can do it in the pool
she already knows that cause like i
don't think i could get away from the
pool thing
nonetheless if i practice when she's not
looking
like in the pool or whatever i'll pull
it off but here's the thing
i'm a little bit older now so my
joints could take a beating
if i wasn't on the supplementation
that's one of the things i was thinking
about as i'm explaining it to her
like i could pull it off just need to up
your joint warfare just
i might have to you know just to first
say you know for a safety
sake as it were nonetheless yeah so take
the joint warfare just in case somebody
asks you to do a backflip
for sure tuck whatever not inside the
pool or other things
let's let's face it you try to climb a
rope or something like this
you shall just get all hurt but if your
joints are good you're good
also krill oil super krill oil
and also that vitamin d yeah get on that
vitamin d
mix a little vitamin d with your cold
water yeah
immunity system strong yeah boost the
immune system
also mulk yeah i was gonna say don't
forget about uh discipline
discipline go discipline powder we got
all kind of discipline
yeah a little bit of that
when you need that little accelerant
yeah to to kind of ignite things try it
out
you might like it yeah and the and the
the jackal
palmer both uh powder and the cans
i think it's sort of the leading uh
flavor it was the tropic one but i think
yeah
i think i think that kind of it's set in
stone i think in my
sour apple apple sniper i'm
out right now by the way jp nels custom
signature jp dunnell signature line
well it doesn't good deal david it's
good too i've tried you know i tried
obviously i tried the uh
the sour apple sniper and it's really
good
yeah it's gonna it's really good it's
really good yeah and and yes
dave burke good deal yes he also has a
flavor coming
a signature flavor yeah yeah yeah
those are interesting too because you
get like it's really orange
yeah afterburner orange yeah
you um these energy drinks the rtd
cans you kind of and i kind of forget
this from time to time too i'm like okay
i need an energy drink but it's not just
the energy
drink you get the discipline and you
don't get like for real chemicals
yeah yeah you don't that's that's so
yeah there's no sugar in it it's
sweetened with monk fruit still tastes
good and but what's even next level
is that it's pasteurized so there's no
chemicals that
keep things stable which we had to go
through
a long period of of
testing and to find the place and to
make
this drink the way it is so yeah check
that out
yeah it's like a um it'd be a disservice
to call it a health
drink even though it essentially is
a health drink you know what i'm
starting to feel over here is that when
we do a podcast like this
where you don't say much during the
podcast portion
maybe that sort of builds some pent-up
conversation in your head
where where where you want to converse
with me about stuff
that yeah and because it seemed like you
had plotted out a whole kind of topic
here that we were going to go into yeah
or that you are going to go around
you know i feel it too but and that you
know
now that you mentioned that you're right
you're actually yeah in real life you're
right and here's what's crazy
that's a long podcast that's three hours
right so i'm thinking okay cool we just
did a three hour podcast
and i'm like echo you know we'll we'll
just kind of burn through people kind of
know what's up they want to support the
podcast they're going to get in the game
they know to go to origenmain.com we can
just kind of let them know
but then we're talking about backflips
that's what we're talking about
really you know how like um what i do is
i screw up because then i bring it up i
should just keep my mouth shut
be like yup backflips cool yep rtd yep
good
warrior kid molk get it yup monk yep but
i don't look
i i i take the bait i take the bait it's
kind of bait
because it's 100 bait well okay so we're
all at home
you know a lot of us i mean you know
some some of us are going out a little
bit more than others but like i'm one of
the people who i'm at home a lot so i
take
i talk to the same four people in my
family varying levels of age
okay you know in maturity levels so
after a while it gets repetitive so when
i see you
you know once a week i'm like hey man
let's let's talk let's face it
and that's not that's a common thing
like because sometimes we can go
straight up two hours before we even
press record
because we're you know whatever whatever
and when you think about it i'm just
realizing this just now
like we kind of rolled in we're like
kind of all business yeah so you're
correct you don't like that you've got a
whole
sort of like excess of conversations
floating around in your head that just
need to come out i don't
all in the time over here i'd be just as
soon like read off the stuff
you tell them where to go and we leave
i'd be down with that i understand
okay all right well hey let's speed it
up but hey let's do you know bear with
me
if you will so yes discipline
can powder all that good for your brain
good for your body keep it
keep keep yourself on the path and
capable by the way monk extra protein in
the form of a dessert
eating dessert like what ice cream or
uh snickers bars for dessert i guess
that's not really a dessert that's more
of a candy bar but like a cake a bundt
cake
but don't do that because that'll take
you off the path yeah
jocko white tea don't forget about that
organic and
you can get all this stuff at
origenmaine.com or you can go to the
vitamin shop
right around the corner if you got one
around the corner from you you can go
check it out there
and then we also at origin main.com
we make all kinds of stuff for you to
wear on your body
things that you can wear when you are
doing jiu jitsu like jiu jitsu
like rash guards t-shirts if you're not
doing jiu-jitsu you
you still need to wear something on your
body wear a t-shirt
you probably need something on your legs
sometimes wear some origin jeans
wear some air origin boots if you need
something on your foot
they got your whole body covered up you
got your whole body covered beanies
do and and here's the thing this is you
kind of throw it in there in the end
like it's no big deal
everything that i just said is 100 made
in america without compromise
you're supporting america you're
supporting local
people that are making things happen our
people
bringing back this industry
being bringing back manufacturing to
america so go to origin origenmaine.com
get yourself some of that stuff if you
need to cover up
your foot sure or other places also
speaking of clothing let's just say
clothes apparel
if you were actually apparel seems more
like a like a
like a it's a bit more spectacular yeah
we'll just say close
how this okay speaking of which jocko
has a store
called jocko store some new things on
there but this is the place
where you can get discipline equals
freedom good
uh get after you know representing while
on the path
with closing from jocko's store so go to
jocklestork.com
just blink with them shirts hats jackets
you know a lot of times i say like oh
this is ours sure
but let me ask you a question is my new
t-shirt up yet
yes all right good yeah your t-shirt is
up
yes some people have noticed it too oh
something
and they knows then they text me you
know jack daniel hill yeah so he texted
me he was like hey hope you're doing
good
that new shirt is awesome and it's not
like he texts me every day too so it was
like a thing
so after many
years of planning because i've been
wanting to do this for you how many
years have we been planning that t-shirt
three three years i've been planning
this t-shirt so it's a t-shirt
on the front of the t-shirt it says two
words
hardcore recondos you all know where
that comes from if you don't
don't worry about it you'll figure it
out at some point and on the back
it's got the it's got phonetic
letters the phonetic letters it has on
the back
are november foxtrot sierra
and if you don't know what those mean
don't worry about it
don't worry if you do know what those
things mean
then you'll probably be when you see me
you'll be seeing me wearing that t-shirt
get some hardcore condos well yep that
one is there
joccostore.com if you see anything else
on there hey man get it
good way to represent while on the path
while supporting
also if
you want to get the book perfectly
wounded
by mike day we got it on the website
chocopodcast.com
in the sections where the books are you
see it books from the episode we got you
there
i'll just click through there it'll take
you to amazon you can buy it boom
straight from amazon
also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already on your
itunes or stitcher google play you know
wherever you listen
to to podcast you know subscribe man
easy one click
boom easy money and there's not just
this podcast we also have
the unraveling podcast which
gonna have its own uh what's it called
its own feed at some point right now
we're kind of
dual broadcasting get people in the game
a little bit make sure that
that you know it's out there but
eventually we'll break that off so look
for
the jocko unraveling podcast we got the
grounded podcast we got the warrior kid
podcast
we got warrior kids soap from
irishoaksranch.com
you can get soap so that you and
everyone you know can
stay clean we got a youtube channel this
is where echo
puts tons of special effects into
two-minute videos and then puts no
special effects
in a three-hour video a lot of people a
lot of people
don't agree with that but that's what
echo's doing and according to him
that's the way it should be so whatever
i also have an album called
psychological warfare
where i will tell you some little things
to do to get through moments of weakness
which we've all got little moments of
weakness attack them
that's what i'm saying if you need some
support attacking you support by fire
position
press play listen to some psychological
warfare
if you need a visual signal for
overcoming a moment of weakness go to
flipsidecanvas.com
dakota meyer he's making all kinds of
cool stuff
also made in america to hang on your
wall and remind you
that you need to stay on the path got a
bunch of books obviously mike day's book
perfectly wounded
we got the code we got leadership
strategy and tactics field manual we got
way the warrior kid one two and three we
got way though we got mikey and dragons
we got discipline equals freedom field
manual
we got the the dichotomy of leadership
and then
the og book extreme ownership
written by me and my brother leif babin
we also have a
leadership consultancy called echelon
front where we solve problems through
leadership go to ashlandfront.com for
details
and also we have
an online training program and i'll tell
you what i'm going to do
i'm going to do some some jocko live
events
on ef online jocko live event so if you
missed the world tour that i did have
you missed the world tour that i did
uh where i went around america talking
to everyone meeting everyone i'm gonna
do
some of those on the internet
so you'll be able to tune in live ask
questions i'm gonna do those
through ef online no dates scheduled yet
but it's coming and and by the way you
don't have to wait because if you want
to talk to me
go to efonline.com and i'm there
answering questions
the whole team's there you can interact
with me
right there so check that out also
if you want to see us in person go to
you can go to
extremeownership.com and come to our
muster which is a leadership conference
next one is phoenix arizona september
16th and 17th
december third and fourth is going to be
in dallas texas
they've all sold out these are going to
sell out too if you want to come
get there early
and of course we also have ef overwatch
if you need
leadership inside your organization we
have
connections from the military that
understand the principles we talk about
go to efoverwatch.com if you want to
support if you want to support service
members around the world
go to america's mightywarriors.org
it is mark lee's mom mama lee and she
is doing her best to provide
for people in the military their
families gold star families all over the
world
you can go there and either donate or
you can get involved and if you're a
glutton for punishment
and you want to hear more of my
cretinous contentions or per chance
for some strange reason you'd like to
hear more of
echo's risible reflections
then you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on instagram and on facebook
echo is that ecwid charles and i am at
jocko willing and of course mike day is
at mike day
53 26 and
speaking of mike thanks once again to
mike
for setting such an awesome example
not only for his deeds on the
battlefield but for the example he sets
in life putting the word out there
explaining what he's been through and
how he has gotten through it
and to all of our other military members
of the past
present and future thanks to all of you
as well for also setting an example
of service and sacrifice
and for allowing us to live in freedom
and
to police and law enforcement and to
firefighters
and paramedics and emts and the
dispatchers and the correctional
officers and the border patrol
bortak
secret service and all the other first
responders
thanks to each of you for your service
as well and
thanks for keeping us safe in our times
of need
and to everyone else out there we know
life is rough and we know there will be
pain and whether that pain is at the
hands of an abuser at the hands of an
enemy or at the hands of nature or time
or disease
there will be pain
but with a man like mike day as an
example
you can overcome you can get through it
you can drive on and you do that by
getting up
every day and getting after it
and until next time this is echo
and jocko out